okay so david check this out we're
making history today today our guest
johann hari flew in from
uh uk yes i've been in miami a while but
yeah okay so here here's the interesting
fact about today's interview folks brace
for impact but you gotta you gotta wait
eight seconds before you
you know you say i'm not sure if i like
this guy or not so
his ted talks have been viewed 78
million plus times 80 million plus times
his books have been translated in 37
different languages he's gotten praise
wait for it from hillary clinton but
also from tucker carlson he may be the
only guy
that has gotten praised by hillary
clinton and tucker
literally in the little venn diagram
there's hilary carlson oprah and noam
chomsky and i'm the one person who's
ever been praised by those stories don't
forget elton john well
i want them all to form an acapella band
and sing about my songs but alton's not
up for it i don't know why
well he would be he would be the main
guy and everybody would just stand there
okay he would mainly stand there but
let's read a couple here's what hillary
clinton said in his unique voice hari
tackles the profound dangers facing
humanity
from information technology and rings
the alarm bell for what all of us must
do to protect ourselves our children and
our democracies elton john says if you
have ever
been down or felt lost this amazing book
will change your life do yourself a
favor read it now i don't know if you
saw his movie by the way did you see
elton john
what a movie
incredible movie i i recommended that
movie to so many friends who were having
a hard time with alcohol because it was
i don't know if you saw the movie or
have you seen the movie i did yes
ridiculous rocky man rocket man you're
ridiculous man go ahead go sorry
sing me something fun fact here's a fun
fact so my dad
is 79 years old hardcore middle eastern
okay with old-school tendencies i
wouldn't say hardcore is like the nicest
guy he is the nicest guy you're making
him out to be like some sort of tears
saddam hussein
[Applause]
right he's more like a gandhi he's like
more
he's very conservative okay in his way
so one day we're staying at the the
palazzo uh suite it's like 15 000 square
feet and it's at the rio and we're
putting an event there and the hostess
comes and he's giving us a tour and he
says just so you know uh sir elton john
stayed here for two months you're the
first family to stay here after all
i'm like great so
my dad's like who elton john he's a
little bit worried he says sir just so
you know the bed you're sleeping in this
elton john slept here last night
my dad is like elton john slept here
last night it was all trippy for him
anyways your dad cannot be more
conservative than my dad to give you a
sense of my dad yeah my dad thinks that
donald trump is like a liberal right my
dad i was very lucky because i'm i'm gay
and my dad thinks donald trump yeah
i was very lucky because i'm i'm gay but
my dad's a bit homophobic but
fortunately he hates women more than he
hates gays so when i told him
when i told him i was gay
uh homophobe he said to me ah son it is
good you are a [ __ ] it means you don't
have to deal with these [ __ ] i was
like wow thanks dad that's really rude
he did he meant it nice he's actually a
very nice person he would never be
actually nasty that just got cancelled
by like
so many people
is he a fan of elton john he does love
that even like the most hardcore the
[ __ ] taliban people who think you're
gay
right i'll tell you i'll tell you one
quick story when i when i used to be in
nightlife miami
i used to hire djs this one you brought
up the word rio i don't think you meant
from brazil
so there was this one uh
brazilian dj and he goes hey adam
guess who my favorite musician is ever
ever i'm like just start guessing
he's like i'll give you a guess i'll
give you a hint it starts with an h
i'm like h i don't know like uh whitney
houston i don't know i'm thinking
you know the h-town boys he goes hampton
john
i go that's elton with an e so anytime i
think of elton john i think of herton
john
he's been to houston john and back yeah
that's hilarious anyway so today we're
going to talk about your latest book
stolen
focus why you can't pay attention and
how to think deeply again now the stuff
you've written about and talked about i
watched you know your your both your ted
talks and by the way it's what's so
crazy is
this weekend i was having my son uh
watch some videos on focus okay and i'm
like here go watch this video and i had
no idea the book the video i hadn't
watched was a video by you
until afterwards i'm like wait a minute
he's on the podcast this week so it was
so interesting because your video's got
a lot of views you you know you get a
lot of praise for them and it's mainly a
lot of this stuff about is about mental
anxiety depression
how to stay focused but
now you've just addiction and we'll
cover some of that stuff but tell us
what inspired you want to write this
book stolen focus well i noticed that
with each year that passed things that
require deep focus like reading a book
were for me getting harder and harder it
was getting more and more like running
up a down escalator you know what i mean
like i could do it but it was getting
harder
and
i just i was really uncomfortable with
what was happening and i was really
uncomfortable with the fact that this
seemed to be happening to everyone
around me and particularly the young
people in my life a lot of them seem to
be almost whirring at the speed of
snapchat right where nothing's still or
serious i'm really curious about talking
about your kids in this respect because
a lot of the book is about kids and i
want to figure out well is something
unusual happening to our attention and
if so what and what can we do about it
so i use my training in the social
sciences at cambridge university to
travel all over the world from miami to
melbourne to moscow to interview over
200 of the leading experts on focus and
attention and just really deeply dig
into their science to figure out what's
going on here
and i learned that there's scientific
evidence for 12 factors that can make
your attention better or can make it
worse and loads of the factors that can
make your attention worse have been
hugely rising in recent years we are in
a real and massive attention crisis i've
reached the conclusion just think about
some simple facts for every one child
who was diagnosed with attention
problems when i was seven and i think
we're pretty much the same age there's
now 100 children given that diagnosis
and that's because they're identifying a
real problem the average american office
worker
now focuses on any one task for only 65
seconds so we're sorry for only three
minutes for college students at 65
seconds so we're we're facing a real
problem here and i think what people
need to understand is if you're
struggling to focus and pay attention as
almost all of us are
your attention didn't collapse your
attention has been stolen from you by
some very big forces and once you
understand what's really happening to us
it opens up a different set of solutions
that we can all achieve together and
what are what is that who has who has
stolen it away from you
so there's a huge range of factors um
and i'll give you one example right
you've got a phone here and you might
you might get some messages on it assume
it's about the show right so i went to
interview one of the leading
neuroscientists in the world a guy named
professor earl miller who's at mit and
he said to me
there's one thing you've got to
understand about the human brain more
than anything else
you can only consciously think about one
or two things at a time
that's it this is a fundamental
limitation of the human brain the human
brain hasn't changed in 40 000 years
significantly ain't going to change on
any time scale any of us are going to
see you can only think about one or two
things at a time but we've fallen for a
massive delusion the average teenager
now believes they can follow six or
seven forms of media at the same time
but what happens is scientists get
people into labs and they say okay do
loads of things at the same time and
then monitor them and what they discover
is you can't do more than one thing at a
time what you do is you juggle very
quickly between them you go from wait
what was that facebook message what did
patrick just ask me what's this on
whatsapp what's on the tv over there you
juggle you juggle you juggle and it
turns out that comes with a huge cost
the kind of fancy name for it is the
switch cost effect when you switch
between tasks you think you're doing
lots of things at the same time so
you're talking to me you're looking at
your phone you're looking at the screen
it turns out you will do
everything you're trying to do less
competently
you make more mistakes you remember less
of what you experience you're far less
creative and this sounds like a small
effect when you first hear about it
you're like yeah i get that but that's
quite small it was shocking talking to
the scientists to realize what a big
effect this is so give you an example of
a pretty small scientific study that's
backed by a wider amount of evidence
hewlett-packard you know the printer
company
even the words paper jam make my whole
body [ __ ] tense up better
hewlett-packard the printer company got
a scientist in to do some research on
this and he split their workers into two
groups and the first group was told just
get on with whatever your task is and uh
you're not gonna be interrupted and the
second group was told get on with your
task you're gonna have to answer a heavy
load of email and phone calls so pretty
much how you you me how we all live most
of the time right
and at the end of it they gave an iq
test to both groups what they discovered
is
the group that had not been interrupted
scored 10 iq points higher than the
group that had to give you a sense of
how big that is if the three of us sat
down now and smoked a fat spliff
together and got stoned our iqs would go
down by five points so being interrupted
all the time in the way that we are is
twice as bad for your intelligence as
getting stoned you'd be better off
sitting at your desk getting stoned and
doing one thing at a time than you would
sitting at your desk being constantly
interrupted and not getting stoned to be
clear you'd be better off neither
getting stoned nor being interrupted
obviously this is a huge effect if
you're interrupted
it takes on average 23 minutes to get
back to the level of focus that you had
before you were interrupted but most of
us never get 23 minutes spare so we're
constantly operating at this diminished
level of brain power a different study
found just getting eight text messages
an hour that doesn't sound like much to
me don't if it does to you
that diminishes your ability to remember
what you're experiencing and to and to
answer questions about it by 30 this is
why professor miller said we are living
at the moment in a perfect storm of
cognitive degradation as a result of all
these interruptions now that's one of
one of the 12 one of many examples but
does that ring true to you guys do you
i'm curious about your own lives yes
i'm curious when i hear that because
i've heard that a lot with multitasking
you know whether it was the yellow book
the power of habit
was it the power habit by hewick
what was his name uh anyways i there's
so many books you can read about focus
right uh but at the same time here's
what i think about you ever seen the
statistic of how much tv people used to
watch
50 years ago versus 30 years ago versus
20 years ago it's like oh my gosh people
watch 45 hours of tv per week this is
insane this is ridiculous it's the end
of the world we have lost focus we no
longer have a relationship we no longer
have this
and i'm like wow so tv ruined everything
we go back you know radio people listen
to 45 hours of radio prior to radio we
used to go outside and we used to play
with our families and we used to do this
okay i can see that part
but i think distractions have started
since
radio right i mean i would assume so i'm
just speculating i don't know the i've
studied the numbers on radio and tv uh
and we can pull it up but then it comes
today with this being a distraction
which are fully absolutely right but i
would be curious to know
is the amount of tv we watched 30 years
ago before this showed up has that been
replaced by the amount of phone
entertainment we watch every week so
there's interesting there's research on
this no actually what we're doing is
we're doing both we're watching tv and
we're tweeting about it actually what's
incredible is tv viewership has not
massively gone down what's happened is
we're switching all the time between the
two which is one of the factors that's
[ __ ] up our ability to focus and i
think and there's a wider thing about
it's absolutely true when you look at
the evidence that our attention is
getting worse a lot of people totally
understandably and this was my initial
response go
you know isn't this a bit like a bit of
a what's called a moral panic right so a
moral panic is when a change happens and
people [ __ ] themselves and go this is
terrible and then actually in the long
arc of history you look back and you go
was that really so bad so think about
for example in the 1950s loads of kids
were reading violent comic books and at
the time there's this huge panic about
it
there's senate hearings and now we look
back and if your kid's reading a comic
book we're like seems very innocuous
so one way of thinking is that it might
be like that but a different way of
thinking about it and i think the
evidence suggests it's more like this
and i learned about this apart from
professor joel nigg who's one of the
leading experts on children's attention
problems in the world this is more like
where we were with obesity in the 1970s
so if you look at a photo of a beach in
the united states and say 1960
it's really weird to us because everyone
is what we would call buff
or or slim everyone you look at you're
like where's everyone else right and you
look at the look at the research there
was basically almost no obesity in 1960
and then a whole series of changes
happened in the way we live the food
supply system completely changed right
what we eat there's no relationship to
what our grandparents ate we built
cities that it's impossible to bike and
walk around right and we became much
more stressed which makes us want to
comfort eat more and all these big
changes
caused an obesity crisis but when people
started warning about this in the 70s a
lot of people said ah you said the sky
was falling when we read comic books you
know you said the sky was falling when
radio came along but yeah this is just a
moral panic but it turned out actually
if we'd listened to them and made the
changes they recommended we wouldn't be
in this obesity crisis now which is so
bad for people's health and i think
what's happening is a kind of obesity
epidemic for our minds now that it's
really important to understand it
doesn't have to be this way right and
one of the reasons why this is so
important
is i would just say to anyone watching
or listening
think about anything you've ever
achieved in your life right whether it's
starting a business like you guys have
whether it's being a good parent whether
it's learning to play the guitar
whatever that thing you're proud of is
it took a huge amount of attention and
focus
sustained attention and focus and when
our ability to focus breaks down as it
clearly is i think
your ability to achieve your goals and
your ability to solve your problems they
also start to break down you can also
when anyone who has a kid who can't
focus you one as and there was an
experience in my life like this that i
can talk about if you like
one of the reasons it's so painful
is you can see oh this kid is is going
to find it much harder to find their way
through the world because they're not
going to be able to sustain focus
they're not going to be able to stick at
difficult things or even with
conversations you know um so yeah it
this is i think this is a big crisis
which is a response to big changes that
are happening from social media to some
aspects of social media to the way we
eat from the hours we don't sleep to the
hours we overwork there's a big range of
factors going on here but
crucially when you understand these
factors we can start to get a handle on
them and i'm sure we're going to get to
that well johann the you you brought up
social media so i wanted to ask
you know pat brought up radio we talked
about tv even computers
every even video games anything that
fits in that category that's all stuff
you did at home and then it was time for
you to get out the get out the house
walk away and then go live your life and
do what you got to do now this goes
everywhere with you okay so my question
is how much of that is related to
this goes everywhere with you and how
much is the act like there's so many
pros and cons you could talk about with
the phone but is this the biggest
culprit these days you know this is
something i thought about a lot because
i actually at the start of researching
stolen focus
i basically had two stories about why my
attention had gotten [ __ ]
one was i thought well you're just
you're lacking in willpower you're weak
why aren't you strong enough to just not
look at this [ __ ] right
and the other story i had was well
someone invented the smartphone right
that was so unfucked me that way right
so because those were the two stories i
later learned it's much more complicated
what's going on and we need a different
kind of solution but at the start my
response was okay
i'm just sick of this i'm tired of being
wired i want to get my brain back so i
went away for three months with no
smartphone and no laptop how did you
survive without for three months it was
really just fascinating i was really
lucky because uh the film writes to one
of my previous books also i had a bit of
money and i went to this place called
provincetown
in cape cod and it was interesting
because there was lots of ups and downs
but the thing that amazed me
and i think really speaks to your
question
is you know i was nearly 40. i thought
maybe maybe my attentions were getting
older
my attention went back to being as good
as it had been when i was 17. i could
sit and read a book for eight hours and
not get stressed it blew my mind how
much my attention came back and at the
end and i later realized there were lots
of changes i made like to what i eat
in those three months that were also
affecting my attention
and i learned about this from scientists
later but i remember at the end of those
three months
just saying to myself
well i'm never going to go back to how i
used to live why would i go back this is
amazing right the pleasures of focus of
being able to follow through on a goal
the pleasures of being able to think
deeply have deep conversations are so
much greater than the shitty rewards of
getting likes and whatever i'm never
gonna go back and then i got a boat
across to boston to my friend who i'd
left my phone and my laptop with
and within a month i was i never quite
went back to as bad as i've been but i
went like 80 back to where i've been
and i only really understood why when
later i went to interview an amazing man
named dr james williams
dr james williams had worked at the
heart of google part of the machinery
that is [ __ ] up our ability to focus
and pay attention and he was really
uncomfortable with what they were doing
one day he spoke at a tech conference to
the people who are designing the things
that obsess your kids and you know and
all of us
and he said to them
if there's anyone here
who wants to live in the world that
we're creating
put up your hand now
and not one of them put up their hand
because they are all being hijacked by
their own creation this wasn't a group
of students no this is a tech conference
tech designers who are designing
like the stuff that you use all the time
right and and he quit
and he became i would argue the leading
expert on attention in the world and he
said to me look the mistake you made
when you went away for three months and
just thought you could hide from it he
said it's like thinking the solution to
air pollution is for you personally to
wear a gas mask right i mean if i lived
in beijing i'd wear a gas mask right
there's a case for gas masks but we've
actually got to solve the problem
instead of just trying to hide from it
you know what you're making me think
about
let me ask you this what currency do you
value the most
you we're all about the same age we're
all one year apart the three of us okay
you're 79 you're 79
i think you're 79 79 yes i know you're
you're the year you're born is what i'm
saying i'm sorry
you look like you're 30 years old but
you're looking very in 1979 yeah okay so
you're 80 80 okay 17 78 79 80. we're
just they're two years apart right
so i've come to realize
let me just ask the question open-ended
for me i'm curious to know what you're
going to say what currency
do you value the most meaning not
currency as in you know i value bitcoin
or ethereum or fiat or gold i'm talking
about what currency do value the most is
it happiness is it stress free is it
super intense engaged is it in the hunt
is it you know sort of what currency i
have an answer i want to see what he's
going to say i want to hear it what
currency do you value the most you know
i had such an interesting conversation
with a guy called dimitri leontiev about
this he's one of the leading
psychologists in russia
and he said to me you know
when russians he said when we look at
americans and british people you know
american and british philosophy is all
about the pursuit of happiness right
it's even in the founding documents of
the country right
we want to be happy and he said you know
russians when we hear that we just laugh
he said children want to be happy he
said you'll have no control of whether
you're happy in your very minor amount
of control he said life is about meaning
and the pursuit of meaning and if you
have meaning that'll carry you through a
[ __ ] ton of unhappiness right or think
about something as simple as going to
the dentist right you go to the dentist
you've got a toothache and you know the
dentist inflicts terrible pain on you
but that has meaning to you because you
know it will stop your tooth hurting
right if you took away that framework of
meaning if i just put a drill into your
face now patrick that would not be a
lovely you know that i went to the
dentist to help it would be a form of
torture right so meaning can carry you
through terrible forms of pain
so for me it's about pursuing meaning
and this is really important for
attention as well
attention evolved to attach to meaning
right a frog will stare longer at a fly
than it will at a stone because the fly
is meaningful and the stone isn't to a
frog they can eat the fly right
and part of one one of the reasons we're
struggling to focus so much now
is that a lot of the stuff we're being
asked to focus on is meaningless
[ __ ] right your attention will slip
and slide off meaningless [ __ ] think
about our school system right
the school system has been redesigned so
it is overwhelmingly about getting kids
to memorize meaningless [ __ ] that
doesn't mean anything to them for tests
are also managers right now after that
change happened when when president the
first the second president bush
introduced no child left behind the
reform that made this
adhd diagnosis went up by 24 in the next
four years because kids can't focus on
meaningless [ __ ]
we can't focus on meaningless [ __ ]
obviously the last quarter of the book
is about how we can help our kids get
their attention back which is about
partly about restoring meaning there's
lots of other things but does that ring
true to patrick about meaning yeah so
what i'm doing is i'm not trying to i
listen to everything you said i'm
looking at this i'm trying to find this
book i read where he said the the
opening line i'll never forget it was a
very and i want to hear what yours is by
the way the currency i'll never forget
we're reading this book i'm in this
phase of reading buddhism and it's like
2006 2007 and i'm just studying
everything i can i'm just like i want to
know how to live more of a meaning life
and
the opening uh i wish i knew that i'll
find her by the time we're done here
he says
happiness is to
uh suffer less okay
happiness is to suffer less
is what this author says and he's a
pretty legendary author he's not like a
regular guy
and
one of the guys that's sitting next to
me whom he and i started the office
together
he says you know what that makes all the
sense in the world to me
we're here in background is your phone
ring all right okay
sure
ironically we're being interrupted by
your phone which is the subject of our
whole time very interesting
he's looking at this and you see now
it's going to take you time to refocus
your mind and i'm not saying this smugly
like we all face
but it's going to take time for you to
realize you're so there right now
because i remember the scene he's locked
in right now
he's sitting next to me and he says
you know what
that's why i'm going to stop being a
business owner and i'm going to go back
to college because i want to suffer less
and i sat there i was
whatever 2007 was 15 years ago i sat
there i'm like
is that really the purpose of life to
suffer less
and he's like i think that's what it is
what the hell are we doing why are we
chasing this why are we going through it
so i think a lot of times based on what
you're saying is whatever your currency
is
you're gonna solve for that adam you
were gonna say your currency is what
i just think the most valuable currency
the the biggest asset you have is time
you know they say time is money like
like you've gone and you've
interviewed hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of people i have done the same
thing
but more with a different angle more on
a financial angle
and because my whole story was i was a
nightlife south beach comedian goofball
miami i said i'm making no money i gotta
get
my [ __ ] figured out when i was in my uh
by age 26 i got a job in finance 10
years later i was like oh my god i've
got all this money i've got all this
time i can i'm working from home what do
i want to do with my free time and i
started interviewing
guys like pat
who made it in business financial
advisors and just basically
understanding how money works
and ultimately what happened was i
figured out okay you gotta have a budget
you have a game plan for your money get
out of debt save your money invest
insurance protection and then i started
asking questions about retirement
retirement and then i realized that
people who are wealthy
they don't just sit around and do
nothing and wait to die they do
something with their time and then this
kind of gets into your meaning
and then if you ask people if you had
millions of dollars in the bank that you
know for some people a million bucks is
a lot of money for some people 100
million bucks whatever the number is
but
if you can own your time
and you if you can do whatever you want
with your free time i said what would
you do and everyone said the exact same
three to four responses number one they
would travel right who doesn't want to
see the world number two they would
pursue a passion something that has
meaning in their life they would do it
for free whether that's photography art
stand-up comedy play baseball whatever
they would do it for free uh number
three they would give back or donate
their time to causes they care about
right whether that's homeless you know
women's shelters kids anything they
would do that and the biggest thing was
leaving a legacy and so you can quote
unquote live forever have kids family
philanthropic and endeavors whatever it
is but at the end of the day that's what
they call you're chilling you could do
whatever you want with your time but
adam i would say i think what you're
saying is so important and and i think
for whatever your currency is and
whatever your set of goals are and i
would agree with all of those goals that
those people are putting forward
you've got to be able to pay attention
to achieve any of them dr williams so i
mentioned before gave me a really good
metaphor he said imagine you're driving
somewhere and someone throws a huge
bucket of mud over your windshield
doesn't matter what you've got to do
whenever you get where you're going the
first thing you've got to do is clean
your windshield right because you're not
going to be able to get anywhere or
achieve anything if you don't do that
and in a way when our attention breaks
down that's like mud on the windshield
right you're just your ability to get
anywhere or do anything is and you
mentioned suffering patrick this is a
real source of suffering right when your
attention breaks down
the way i would put it and this really
became clear to me in provincetown when
i had that time off and i began to be
able to focus again
was it's like you become a kind of stump
of yourself right you can sense what you
would have been if you've been able to
apply yourself but you feel like you
can't get that and that's why when you
understand these 12 factors that are
damaging our focus it opens up there's
two things we there's two different ways
we can respond to this right we've got
to do both the first is there are all
sorts of things as isolated individuals
i think of it as offense and defense
right so we've got to play defense we've
got to protect ourselves and our kids
from these factors that are pouring acid
on our attention all the time so i'll
give you go through dozens of examples
installed and focus if i give you one
example i should have brought it it's in
my case outside i've got a um
uh plastic safe it's called a k-safe you
take off the lid you put in your phone
you put the lid on you turn the dial and
it will lock your phone away for
anything between five minutes and a
whole day right i won't sit down to
watch a movie with my partner unless we
both imprison our phones i won't have
dinner with my friends unless everyone
agrees to imprison their phones oh you
make these demands before people get
together because it's difficult at first
but then people start to get the
pleasure of it's difficult for me but
then you start to get the pleasure of a
deep conversation of deep engagement
yeah so that's one level of response
yeah i think i think you uh i think
there is an area for what you just said
i fully like that like you know jennifer
and i right now when we go to dinner
uh and we're with the kids here's what
else i said babe put my phone in your
purse okay oh wow and that's kind of
like hey put the phone in your purse
uh it's not my purse and boom after
dinner we have good conversations with
and i really enjoy talking to the kids
and i'm the one that's always asking
questions but i will say this to you so
we've lost focus right we're saying that
focus is less which i don't disagree but
i but i'm very i'm a little bit
skeptical about it and challenge me on
this challenge please i want to hit the
channel yeah so because to me it's the
way i see it is would you say
innovation is better today
50 years ago or a hundred years ago when
would you say innovation is better
it's hard to measure that's fantastic
like advancement and innovation it's
very hard to measure these things as far
more human beings now than there were 50
years or 100 years ago so
you know we've got eight billion
people's brains on it now as opposed to
a billion people's brains fifty years
ago i think it's very hard to compare i
don't know if it was a billion fifty
years ago i was probably i think about
the best i think that the
democratization of technology is higher
than ever think about it they say you
know that the phone you have in your
pocket that's the exact same technology
that nasa used to get people into space
into the sections and now everybody has
not just so this is what i'm this is
what i'm trying to say
like you know okay so for example i did
these two tests okay so i went and
bought this uh uh i didn't buy it greg
dinkins shout out he got this for me as
a gift he says pat you got to put this
ring on i said okay so aura ring
i put it on and um
he looks on my stuff more than i look at
my stuff i'm half the time i'm running
out of batteries and he says you got to
charge it but the other day we're
sitting there we're having an electric
hey pat how can you go off of four to
six hours of sleep i'm like i don't
honestly have a clue but i can pull it
off right i'm saying he knows your sleep
schedule yeah no no so because it tells
you everything your readiness all this
other stuff right and and so and by the
way i'm not i'm we're not doing a
sponsorship anything so this is not like
a sponsorship deal i'm doing i'm just
telling you guys what this experience
was like so then we sit down we look at
it with the guys and they say
pat
you slept five hours
but you were in rem deep sleep for three
and a half hours and i slept seven and a
half hours and i was in rem only two and
a half hours i'm like okay maybe we need
to learn our bodies better so you're
able to have deeper sleep then i'm
having deeper sleep i have lighter
service okay i don't know so then the
thinking comes and introduced me to this
other guy we're talking about at lunch
yesterday the dna company yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know if you heard about the dna
company you they take your saliva and
they come back and they take tell you
everything your temperament you know how
you will go here one second pissed off
two seconds later you're telling a joke
and you're just laughing about you
forgot it but you moved on right and
your bone density your testosterone your
estrogen your food what you should eat
what you do what your body doesn't and
i'm listening to the ceo of the company
so i'm like my so i had my wife and i
because you know a lot of time when
these guys say they're just trying to
sell something i'm very skeptical and
i'm like
that made sense and jennifer's just like
what
how have you guys ever had i've never
met this guy before this made sense that
made sense this made sense okay so it
made me think about a couple different
things i don't know if everything a
hundred percent applies to everybody
because when i think about an athlete so
football is going on right now right you
think about a linebacker you think about
a quarterback
is
in huddle he's looking at the situation
the guy's speaking to him audience the
fans are screaming and hollering
defense is running around blitz is
coming from here the guy's stepping back
are they gonna do the blitz my guy's
going behind me i gotta step out i come
back i got three four seconds to look at
my three different receivers
not lose the fumble i'm getting all this
situation that's so that's to me that's
all like 50 different multitasking yeah
you're doing so and almost no one can do
it the reason why you're right the great
guys you're totally most important so
that goes to a point which which i want
to put it on you is is one multitasking
a muscle that we can improve in but
we're always going to do better for
doing on one thing fully i fully believe
that you know uh
the one thing like you know that's
that's the best way to do it you're to
be better focused on one thing but is
multitasking something we can get better
in and if yes
is that someone's wiring is it some you
know the nurture versus nature with the
dna the individual that some can handle
it more than others what would you say
to that so i asked the leading experts
on this i looked at the research and it
was kind of depressing you can get very
slightly better at it but the truth is
you can't get much better at it but i
want to just say you said adam that i
think is really important there were
loads of things what you said about
sleep as well patrick remind me to come
back to that but you said this thing
that's really important which is oh you
know the phone you use has the
technology that nasa were using like 30
years ago that feels like
democratization and in some ways is
but you've got to ask yourself what is
that technology being deployed for is it
being used to make your life better or
is it being used to invade your
attention now it could be used to make
your life better we could democratize it
at the moment it isn't so and this was
explained to me by some of the people
who designed these apps some of the
leading figures in silicon valley who've
subsequently kind of spoken out because
they're horrified by what they've done
so let's say you pick up your phone now
patrick and it's isn't it funny how it
feels quite invasive to touch someone's
phone sorry i don't mean to it feels
like weirdly personal like i've touched
your body exactly exactly
don't mean to me now yeah
the um the
the when you let's say you open your
facebook now or any of the major social
media apps
facebook or whichever one you choose
immediately starts to make money and it
makes money in two ways
the first way is obvious you start to
see ads
we all know how that works the second
way is much more important
everything you do on facebook is scanned
and sorted by their algorithms because
they're building up a profile of who you
are so let's say that you like
donald trump
uh bette midler and you tell your mom
you just bought nappies okay so i don't
think anybody is literally
gonna be like the [ __ ] uh
but let's imagine so it'll figure out
okay you like donald trump you're
probably conservative you like bette
midler if you're a man you're probably
gay and you're talking about diapers
okay you've got a baby it's building up
an enorm imagine it's got tens if not
hundreds of thousands of data points
about you it's learning all about you
data data data in order to be able to
manipulate you because you are not the
customer of facebook you're the product
they sell to advertisers so they can the
reason why they make the big bucks is
they go to an advertiser and they say we
can target someone so directly you're
selling diapers okay we can make sure
your ads don't go to me i don't have a
baby we can make sure the ads go only
people you want to target conservative
gay people with babies
we can get you there right that's how
that's why they're so lucrative but what
this means is
every time you close facebook or tiktok
or snapchat or any of them
what happens is those revenue streams
disappear so the business model of all
of the existing social media companies
is very simple
all of their engineering power all of
their algorithms all of this genius they
have is geared towards one thing
figuring out how do we get patrick and
adam and their kids to pick up their
phone more often and scroll for longer
right it is designed to invade our
attention
sean parker one of the biggest initial
investors in facebook said yeah the
napster dude said um we designed
facebook specifically to invade people's
attention we knew what we were doing and
we did it anyway something new yeah well
it's a it's a much deeper form of
invasion so you think about a tv ad
let's say you placed an ad during the
johnny carson tonight yeah right that's
a blanket thing that's going to whatever
it was back then 50 million people
that's very different to something that
knows what you messaged your mom about
last night that's learning all these
deep patterns about your mind yeah i
think the dm part the private
conversations that's your your
that's my privacy but it's not a privacy
that privacy is part of it yeah but it's
that they can learn how to hack your
attention
much more accurately they're learning
the weaknesses
do you think that's innovation or do you
think that's manipulation well it's a
form of innovation but it's a form of
innovation that harms our attention and
has all sorts of negative outcomes and
it's important to understand we can have
all the good stuff about social media
without this this aspect is designed and
i've been i want social dilemma right
you remember social dynamics i'm sure
you've seen it yeah
oh my gosh it's the end of the world so
i want social dilemma
and i sat there and i said
okay
i can see that uh got it the the movie
that made the biggest impact wasn't a
social dilemma to me was a movie called
disconnected which we can talk about the
movie disconnected but let's stay on
social dilemma so i watched this movie's
the documentary social oh my gosh former
president of this and former president
of that and these guys are doing this
and here's what we're doing our
intention is to do this i'm like okay
what's new about this like okay so for
example my kids what do parents do we
look for markers on how to
gather data and intel on our kids to get
them to stay focused because i can't say
son let me tell you here's a book here's
a
biography of aristotle i want you to
read it that would never work but here's
a diaries of wimpy kid oh my gosh i'll
read 50 of them so i think the same kid
that is obsessed with reading diaries of
wimpy kid and the parent only targets
what interests him we're now that big
kid that's interested in different
things that it just suggests and great
marketers know how to penetrate that
interest so the difference is when when
you're the difference is about the goals
that you have for the individual so when
you're learning what your kid wants your
goal for your child is for your child to
be able to flourish to have a good life
to be able to focus to be effective in
the world right
when facebook or tick tock are learning
about your child
those are not the goals that facebook
and tick tock have for your child they
have one goal let's make your child
scroll as long as possible and pick
their phone up as often as possible
that's the only goal they have just like
the head of kfc his only goal is can i
get your kid to eat kfc the only goal
they have is can we get them to scroll
so you the issue isn't do you learn
things about people in order to guide
them that's a good thing in many
contexts in the context specifically of
learning things about people in order to
guide them to scroll as often as
possible and pay as little attention as
possible that's a bad thing now that's
bad for individuals and bad for the
society so but go go pull up mcdonald's
and go to uh type in mcdonald's
pineapple burger okay i can be hungry
here yeah i i had a mcdonald's breakfast
this morning did you really actually let
me put it you can tell from my channel
i'm gonna tell you i would the last time
i had a big mac check this out go to
just type in mcdonald's go to images oh
man yeah let me tell you so they came
out with this stuff but they gave this
guy some mcdonald's years ago they came
out with this idea of a mcdonald's
pineapple burger it was such a massive
failure because they thought the healthy
people are going to be interested in
this pineapple burger and it failed
right so mcdonald's goes and brings
ronald mcdonald okay
and ronald mcdonald used to be a big hit
if you went to mcdonald's it was
everywhere now what was mcdonald's
strategy with ronald mcdonald here's
what ronald mcdonald did they knew
if they got kids addicted to ronald
mcdonald kids can't get in the car to
come to mcdonald's they have to tell
mommy and daddy to go to mcdonald's if
they
persuade it and won the kids over
they're automatically going to get a
family of four or five so kids meal
ronald mcdonald next thing you know it's
a business model and by the way here's
what's crazy about it do you know
mcdonald's for 30-something years
prof
they profited every year for 30-plus
year until one year
when the whole uh uh obama and um
michelle obama no no obama and romney
were going at it and you remember that
one thing when sandy hook happened and
then uh romney's about to become
president and benghazi situation he's
just really the third debate he
destroyed obama it was terrible was not
a good thing for obama and the fourth
debate i'm on a flight with bill
o'reilly and uh dennis miller they're
doing a show we're going to burbank to
vegas because they're doing this i'm
like bill what happened or romney and
they said let me tell you what happened
here's what happened here he says the
consultants of romney said you don't
have the votes of single women and you
have to stop maybe talk they don't like
it when you bash obama with benghazi
kick back on the fourth debate and he
did that he lost guess what mcdonald's
said we're gonna start selling salad is
there any way you could take this off
the screen because it's not genuinely
giving me cravings sorry yeah you know
it's making me hungry yeah so they they
went to they went to salads okay they
said we're gonna do salad do you know
the year mcdonald's went to salad first
they lost money because they forgot who
their customer was their customer was
the kid that forced parents to take them
to mcdonald's which i've done many many
times based on the kids meals so i think
that's called capitalism and innovation
and some of the guys today the way
they're doing it it's way more intrusive
totally agree it is intrusive
but it's a business model it's not just
that it's intrusive it's that it leads
to catastrophic outcomes so we all know
about the obesity crisis it means that
people die i think the figure is seven
years earlier than they otherwise would
and you're right
part of how this works is so for example
more 18 month old children know what the
mcdonald's m means than know their own
last name so from the moment we're born
we are taught to associate positive
feelings with unhealthy food and as you
can see from my chins i'm as much a
victim of that as anyone right um but i
think it's important to understand so i
think part of what you're arguing
patrick which is really important to
think about is
okay there's some harm here but we just
choose this this is capitalism we choose
it and what i would argue is we're
choosing it in a context that is
absolutely loaded against us if i
covered you guys with itching powder
right now
um you would scratch and at some level
you would be choosing to scratch but
equally you wouldn't have chosen to
scratch if i hadn't covered you with
itching powder right so you made a
choice but not in an environment that
you chose in a similar way there are all
sorts of things that are happening to us
that we don't choose that are making us
much more vulnerable to making these bad
choices and people can feel that you
know people are choosing it but they're
unhappy with it in the same way that you
know when i used to eat kfc every day i
had a period in my 20s yeah i liked the
kfc i didn't like being so overweight
that i couldn't walk upstairs right so
in a similar way
um we're making these choices but this
is way more invasive than anything that
kfc can do to you right i mean kfc can
put an ad on the tv they can show that
tempting burger image mcdonald's can but
this is and i think there are lots of
things happening to us that are um
that are making us more vulnerable to
this remind me to come back to sleep so
i really want to talk about your point
but even let's just think about the way
how the way we eat is affecting our
ability to focus so so watch this i
think you are social dilemma
i think you are a form of social dilemma
let me explain i think you are a form of
facebook twitter
youtube and i applaud you for it and
here's what i mean by it i'm on ted
talks youtube channel right now okay
and i'm on 11 days give me let's go to
let's yeah go to ted talks youtube
channel and scroll down to a video from
i don't know go two weeks ago okay
now ted talks so everybody knows now go
to ted talks not ted there's another one
type in ted uh talks
okay and they have another channel with
32 million so go a little lower go a
little lower go a little lower a little
lower no what did you do did you click
on that okay right there click on that
okay so how many subscribers can you
zoom in a little bit to show how many
subscribers that is 34 million
subscribers now go to videos go to
videos and just keep scrolling down to
like two weeks keep going down just
scroll scroll until it goes like to a
month ago okay keep scrolling keep
scrolling what are you doing okay go
type in videos click on the videos at
the top your videos and just keep
scrolling down yeah keep scrolling down
keep scrolling down keep scrolling down
keep scrolling now keep scrolling keep
going keep going until we go to like two
weeks okay
go to two weeks ago this is a 33 million
subscriber channel okay 33 million
subscriber channel
tens of millions of eyeballs okay
now zoom into somebody right there you
went away from videos again i don't know
why you keep doing it reset on me okay
so go here to
uh stay go go to one of them right there
all right
395 views
on a 33 million subscriber channel
zoom in a little bit so we can see the
amount of crazy a thousand views zoom in
three two one 395 views 790 views on a
33 million subscriber channel so watch
this how is it
that johan here
is able to get
80 million plus eyeballs on the same
channel that thousands of other people
can't even crack a thousand views here's
what i think i think
your messaging
is more innovative than others and
you're able to connect to us as the
audience than them how many of them have
a book that they're publishing that
would love to be sitting here right now
so we can sell a few thousand books so
the point i'm trying to make is i think
we're in the game of attention and
you've gotten the attention of former
president your former you know hillary
clinton elton john tucker carlson how
did you get their attention so i think
credit goes to the innovator who's able
to get the eyeballs i don't see a
difference between all of us here in
social dilemma i may be wrong correct me
if i'm wrong i'm all yours so i think
you made a really important point i want
to just think through it carefully
so
if this was an argument about is tech
good or is tech bad i'd be on your side
tech is good we don't want to all
convert and join the amish no disrespect
to any amish people they're cheating if
they're watching right now
that's not the debate the debate tech is
good we want to have the technology we
have we want to be able to reach people
the way you and i do the debate is
what tech
designed for what goals working in whose
interests so i think there's an analogy
that can help us to understand that i
stress again in the book i go through
loads of things that we can all do as
individuals to protect and boost our
attention and the last quarter of the
book is particularly what we can do for
our kids attention which i know will be
very important to you as a dad so maybe
we can talk about that as well
but i think there are things we also
have to do collectively because at the
moment it's like someone is pouring
itching powder over us all day and then
leaning forward and going hey buddy you
might want to learn how to meditate then
you wouldn't scratch so much to which
the logical response is okay well [ __ ]
you i'll learn to meditate but we need
to stop you pouring itching powder on me
so it's a very practical example
all within capitalism of a historical
analogy that i think could help us to
think about this because there's
something in the past that was [ __ ]
up people's attention and we dealt with
it and i think it can teach us how to
deal with some of the things that you're
talking about where we can keep the good
exactly the good stuff that you're in
favor and i'm a favorite patrick without
this harm so you guys are going to
remember because we're the same age it
used to be normal that people put leaded
gasoline in their cars right i remember
my mom putting a lot of gasoline into
her little red mini that she had right
and it was discovered that exposure to
lead [ __ ] your ability to think and pay
attention particularly for children it's
a disaster right it's actually known
about going all the way back to the
1920s but the lead industry funded kind
of [ __ ] denial for a long time but
in the end by the 70s by the time we
were kids the early 80s it was just
undeniable so a group of moms got
together and they said okay why are we
allowing this why are we allowing these
companies to [ __ ] our ability kid's
ability to focus you're saying with the
gas yeah with the so what happens isn't
lead in pencils and schools not anymore
okay because exposure to lead is so bad
for you i mean it still is a bit but
they're not in a way that you can suck
on it like they used to
um because exposure to lead is terrible
it used to also be in pain people used
to paint their houses with leaded paint
right what these moms did not say it's
really important thing about what they
didn't say they didn't say let's ban all
gasoline they didn't say let's ban all
pain right they said let's ban the
specific thing in the in the gasoline
and the pain that is [ __ ] our kid's
ability to focus which is which is the
lead right they led a campaign they
succeeded right there's no more lead in
in in paint and gasoline as a result the
center for disease control says the
average american child had a boost of
between three to five iq points because
they were no longer exposed to this
pollutant right now i think and don't
really matter what i think what a load
of the experts that i interviewed think
is there's an analogy with social media
right so go back to what we were saying
what's the what's the equivalent of the
lead in the social media how do we have
the social media dopamine addiction what
would you say well i think it's the
business the current business model
right which is one form of capitalism
that can be replaced by a different form
of capitalism so go back to what we said
right
at the moment you open facebook
every minute you scroll they make more
money and every minute you put your
phone down the revenue stream disappears
that's it so the whole machinery is
designed and for tik tok and for
snapchat the whole [ __ ] lot of them
it's all designed
how do we raid your attention the most
right that's it that's their model
but when i interviewed lots of the
people who designed key aspects of the
internet like a guy called azeraskin who
designed something called infinite
scroll that's the heart of most websites
including youtube the one we just looked
at
he said to me look the solution here is
very simple
when it comes to the tech component i
stress again there's 12 elements i write
about in the book but for this component
um you've got to ban that business model
just like we banned the lead in the
paint just a business model that is
designed to secretly track you in order
to figure out the weaknesses in your
attention
hack them break your attention open
break your kid's attention open and i
remember saying to aza i shook my head
like you just did patrick and i said
wait wait a that seems like a really big
thing but b
what would happen if i open facebook the
next day right would it just say sorry
guys we've gone fishing he said of
course not what would happen is they
would move to a different business model
and there are two different business
models that are happening in this
building right now
the first business model is subscription
right everyone here there'll be some
people here who've got netflix
subscriptions hbo subscriptions we all
know that's a former capitalism you'd
pay a small amount you you for access
right or the second is one that's
definitely in this building because i
used it before we came here you've got a
sewage system here right now before we
had sewers we had [ __ ] in the streets we
got cholera so we all pay
to build and maintain the sewers
together and we all own the sewers you
own the sewers here in in this part of
florida i own the sewers in london and
las vegas the places i live we all own
the sewers now it may be that like we
own the sewage pipes together we might
want to own the information pipes
together because we're getting the
equivalent of cholera for our brains but
the really important thing about this is
what changes and it comes back to what
we were saying like you were saying
about your son with goals right at the
moment the only goal of social media the
way it's designed is to invade your
attention break it open and keep
harvesting it right but under this
different business model whether it's
subscription or a sewage-like system
what happens is all the incentives
change suddenly you stop being the
product that they sell and you become
the customer something like what does
patrick want oh patrick wants to be able
to meet up with his friends offline
we'll design facebook to make that
easier facebook want them adam wants to
be able to pay attention okay we'll
design facebook to heal his attention
instead of hacking it but to get there
you've got to change the business model
which is entirely within capitalism this
is not anti-capitalism i i i don't know
because uh so so i get how it upsets
some people because
of the amount of power
the area that concerns me with these
virtual governments is a complete
different thing than what concerns that
individual you were talking about
because to me
uh
i've bought a lot of products that was
based off a great ad
i've seen and been inspired by many
stories
if it wasn't for the algorithms my son
would have never watched a video from
you
right that the the video that if it
wasn't for the algorithms to buy certain
products for myself
okay so this isn't an argument against
algorithms just to say this isn't this
is an argument against the ads it's like
saying so an algorithm is like a recipe
yeah an algorithm decides what order you
see things in social media right but
you're saying facebook shouldn't make
money based on the ads because they're
gathering intel based on me to show me
products that i'm going to buy and that
becomes a business model that facebook
we should change that model no they
shouldn't have a business model that's
designed to maximally invade people's
attention you can still have algorithms
in the different you need to have
algorithms
but i it's like saying because i agree
with you
do you know what i'm saying
i don't have a problem with eating a kfc
bucket i love eating a kfc bucket but i
know that it comes with the cost that i
become obese yeah so
the thing you're describing has some
benefits of course just like eating kfc
has plenty of benefits to me i love it
right but it comes with a cost the
question is is the cost outweighing the
benefits should we eliminate that from
people should we eliminate from people
hurting themselves like should we
eliminate you know the the four okay so
maybe let me ask you this what do you
think about the system of capitalism
i think markets are a really important
tool every society that's ever abolished
markets regresses to extreme poverty i
don't think markets should be everything
i think there are other forces that are
really good and healthy in this society
as well the two most popular
institutions in the united states are
medicare and the military neither of
which are run according to markets so
you know you want to have a mixture you
want to have a really strong market
economy and really strong countervailing
forces that operate on different
different models so it's not about this
isn't about being anti-capitalism this
is about saying the current model we
have and this isn't by the way just true
of uh this one factor of the 12 that i
write about in stolen focus the harming
our attention it's true of lots of them
um we can talk about the food industry
for example or or uh air pollution
there's a whole or the factors that are
causing us so much stress stress
destroys your ability to focus and pay
attention but the the
the question is not are these things
good the question is do they come with
costs and do the costs outweigh the
benefits and as a model that is
destroying think about the fact that one
small study for example backed by a
wider body of evidence found out that
the typical american college student now
focuses on only one task for only 65
seconds expl children with attention
problems are blowing up right think
about the fact the average american
office worker only focuses on any one
task for three minutes right imagine
your whole life passing in a hailstorm
of three minutes here three minutes
there three minutes there what was that
what was this this is the texture of our
everyday lives and at the moment we're
in a race right at the moment to one
side you've got all these 12 factors
that are causing attention problems many
of which are on course to get much worse
paul graham one of the biggest investors
in silicon valley said that the world
would be more addictive in the next 40
years than it was in the last 40. think
about how much more addictive tik-tok is
to your child than facebook right so
these forces are on course to learn how
to hack our attention in ways that will
make facebook look like a [ __ ] tetris
on a game about what was what was it
sorry
you had a point with capitalism and
sorry i'm sorry i caught you off sorry
no no
i think that's where we were this is
good i like exactly the banter we're
having i don't want you i want you to i
want this is like that we're learning
we're we're getting two plays yeah where
i'm going with this is like i'm sitting
with chip wilson the founder of
lululemon right and i'm interviewing
this guy and you know we all know
lululemon and they by the way they
started off being 88 of their clients
were only women and now it's like
55 percent of 40 45 of their customers
would you have ever thought like 40
percent
still think it's 80 20. okay and he said
he said this i was at the lululemon
store the other day i got a couple
shorts i think i don't understand i
don't know if we bought lululemon or
nikes he would notice because he picked
them up uh but we were at the lululu i'm
like you know what i would probably
sport that okay i would probably wear
that for a workout the material is good
i'll i'll sport it but here's what he
said to me he says 20 years from now
being in shape will be irrelevant i said
tell me why he says he says
everyone's going to be in shape 20 30
years from now i said explain that to me
that doesn't make any sense because
everything nowadays about sitting down
not moving you're not doing this you're
not doing what i mean we're all going to
be in shape he says because you know how
everyone's got a smartphone right now i
said yeah he says everyone's going to
have smart clothes i said what does
smart clothes mean smart clothes are
going to say here's where you're at sit
down stand up a little bit move you got
to do this your temperature you're going
to look at your shirt that's going to
say here's where you are you you drank
too much you know drink more water take
a sip of this smart clothes are going to
get us to be more aware of what we're
doing he says the idea of being in shape
is going to be nothing like today you
see somebody with a six-pack maybe not
even today because today we see so many
people that are
in shape as well you see somebody with a
six-pack so you'll be impressed he says
in 20-30 years you're gonna be like yeah
whatever everyone's in [ __ ] because what
we're wearing now is he right or wrong i
don't know is innovation advancing where
they're seeing problems where
entrepreneurs like himself are sitting
there saying how can i
be the solution to this problem that
this person's having i think innovation
wins i think the part that concerns me
is the following the part that concerns
me is
when uh uh
when the like you know in 2010 i don't
know what year it was i went and sat
down with a psychologist a lot of stress
in my life i'm like man what the hell is
going on like is this business stuff
worth it
why is this so much stress i one night i
come home two o'clock in the morning my
body's bouncing off the ground my wife's
like what what is going on she calls my
dad my dad comes over i go to the
hospital he's like i think he's having a
heart attack they're like no this guy's
not having a heart attack what have you
done the last few weeks i said i've been
just on the road busting it going on
three four hours of sleep he says dude
your body's exhausted
okay
and this has happened on my hand full of
times in my career right and so they put
on couple ivs on me and then i went to
work and
but i was kind of like is this worth it
is it worth you working as hard as
you're working and being in the hunt and
like i wouldn't want it any other way
than being in the hunt doing something
big in my life but i i think sometimes
you know we
we try so hard to move the pain and the
challenges away i i want to have
pushback i want to have some being in a
moment where it's stretched it's
probably stressful to be in a fourth
quarter and performing it's probably
stressful to have kids
you know last time i'm sitting down with
dylan and tico and i said uh dylan how
many kids you want to have when you grow
up and dylan's like daddy i think i just
won three last night i'm talking to
dylan about this just yeah i said why
three he says honestly daddy because
i think four is a lot of work like what
he says you guys got four and i see it
it's a lot of work i think i want to
have one less so you want to have one
he's got an eight month so yeah
his eight-year-old kid is telling me
that he wants to have only three kids
but i think i think the the the name of
the game is
overcoming an obstacle or a challenge or
some of those things these distractions
are never going to go away it's been the
job of everybody to distract them what
concerns me is when
the big pharmaceutical companies when i
go and met with the therapist it's like
yeah take this medication it's going to
solve it i'm like no bro i don't want
this
give me a real permanent solution you
know why don't you take this over here
why don't you take that over here once
you take this over i'm like is this
really the so i lost a friend one time
too pro my best friend in the world i
lost because he was taking 50
vicodins a day
in front of me he took eight in front of
me the guy got three
d what do you call it when you're
driving under the influence he wasn't
drunk he was on vicodin he got into
three car accidents and we went to jail
we had to go get him like what are we
doing took him to a rehabs a rehab place
for two weeks and then eventually you
know he died but just to go back to this
there's so many things what you just
said that are so important
um so like you i am passionately in
favor of innovation innovation is the
thing that moves the human race forward
the single if you look at all the
research about innovation
all serious innovation requires deep
thought it requires periods of mind
wandering it requires really sustained
focus and attention so if you're in
favor of innovation as we both are
passionately
the thing you most want to get right is
attention because humans who can't pay
attention can't innovate right if you if
you can only think in 65 second bursts
good luck thinking of something new
right you'll never get there so if i
think about all the really impressive
innovators i've ever met from oprah to
noam chomsky
they are people who make space to think
deeply to really properly pay attention
so i think
and i wanted to just go back to
something you mentioned before i also
really want to talk about childhood
because i'm really fascinated you've got
an eight-year-old and i think this is
there's specific elements that are
destroying our children's attention that
i think will really vibe with the
solutions will really vibe with you but
let's think about sleep because you
mentioned that a few times in exhaustion
right
so we are in the united states a
chronically sleep deprived society only
15 of us wake up feeling refreshed it
was one of the weirdest things that
happened to me in provincetown when i
took those three months off
i remember one morning about a month in
i woke up
and i went into the kind of um kitchen
i was like i feel really weird what do i
feel and i couldn't place it
and i realized i had woken up and i
wasn't tired right it was the first time
i remember that happening to me in my
adult life because we live at such a
level of exhaustion 40 of americans are
chronically sleep deprived so i
interviewed loads of the leading
scientists on sleep people at harvard
medical school and other places and
there was a few bits of science that
really threw me on this if you stay
awake for 19 hours which sounds like
nothing right 19 hours
you will be as your attention
deteriorates as badly as if you got
legally drunk
there was one experiment done by a guy
called dr charles seisler i interviewed
at harvard medical school
he put together two forms of technology
there's a technology that can track your
eyes to see what you're looking at and
there's a technology we all know about
that can scan your brain so he gets
tired people and he puts them into this
machinery and what he discovered was a
complete head [ __ ]
you can be awake you can be looking
around you can appear to be as awake as
you and me but whole parts of your brain
kind of gone to sleep right you know we
use that phrase i'm half asleep turns
out that's not a metaphor a lot of us
are literally half asleep a lot of the
time and this is so important because
professor roxanne prichard who's at the
university of minneapolis explained to
me a lot that um
that when you're sleeping your brain is
repairing
it's healing itself so throughout the
day something called metabolic waste
builds up in your brain it's what she
calls brain cell poop right and when you
sleep your cerebral spinal fluid
channels open up and a kind of water
rinses through your brain and it clears
out all this [ __ ] that builds up during
the day if you don't sleep properly if
you don't get eight hours sleep a night
which feels like a luxury to a lot of
people in the united states if you don't
sleep eight hours a night your brain
does not clean itself this is why people
who sleep less are far more likely to
get dementia you literally build up with
[ __ ] in your brain your attention will
be much worse you know that kind of
hungover feeling you have when you're
tired it turns out that's because your
brain is literally clogged up so the
single best thing you can do for your
attention along with exercises at an
individual personal level
is get more sleep right um so yeah the
science on this is really clear and i'm
pretty shocking there are some it sounds
like you might be one of them there's a
there's some natural genetic variation
in terms of how much sleep people need
and some people are really lucky and
just naturally need less sleep but that
it's quite a small part of the
population and some people are unlucky
and need a shit-ton i actually agree
with you i i agree with you that you
know the more and more
and by the way even the bodybuilding
world you this gentleman you spoke to
that said sleeping helps with men's like
you're taking a mental [ __ ] like you
you're releasing all the toxins you know
out of your body's
so
you know the same thing happens when
you're sleeping your muscles don't grow
when you're working out your muscles
grow when you rest your muscles when
you're sleeping your muscles are grown
so i can actually see that you know
going back to focus so let's talk about
focus because sure you said i fully
believe that if you know noam chomsky
and oprah went free to innovate at the
highest level you have to
learn how to be fully focused i 100
agree with that part so let's talk about
somebody that's right now you know got
all the distractions we all got they got
one of these they got an ipad they got
kids they got family they got you know
their jobs are trying to get a side
hustle they got you know all these other
things that they're doing
and they're having a hard time stay
focused what is the basic formula for
one to stay focused so there's lots of
things and i go through dozens in the
book but i'll give you an example of one
that
really helped me in my life and i think
will help people in that position so i
learned a lot about the science of
something that called flow states
everyone listening will have experienced
a flow state a flow state is when you're
doing something that's really meaningful
to you and you just get into it and
you're in the zone and it's like time
falls away and your ego falls away and
you're just in it the way one rock
climber put it is a flow state is like
when you feel like you are the rock
you're climbing right so for me it would
be when i write for someone else it
might be when they make bagels or they
do brain surgery or they play the guitar
but a flow state is really important for
attention for two reasons a flow state
is the deepest form of attention you can
bring right when you're in a flow state
you are deeply focused and a flow state
is the easiest form of attention once
you get into it it's not like memorizing
facts for an exam
it's like you know like oh [ __ ] how do i
do this you're in it you don't it's not
even you don't even have to want to
there's no effort involved you're just
it's called a flow state because you are
just flowing right so i wanted to
understand given this is the easiest
form of attention once you're in it and
the deepest [ __ ] how do we get more of
this i went to interview professor
mahali cheek sent me high e you have no
idea how long it took me to learn how to
say that who is the leading ex was that
sadly
sadly died recently but he was the
leading expert on flow states he studied
them for over 50 years he's the man who
coined the phrase
and he discovered a [ __ ] ton of stuff
about this i think there's three that
would really help the person you're
talking about three key facts if you
want to maximize your chances of getting
into a flow state and there's no
guarantee but if you want to maximize
your chances you've got to do three
things
firstly you've got to narrow down to one
goal
if you're trying to do more than one
thing at a time you'll never get into
flow choose one goal
secondly it's got to be a goal that's
meaningful to you right
if it's not meaningful you won't get
into flow and thirdly it will really
help if you choose a goal and this is
counterintuitive at first it will really
help if you choose a goal that's at the
edge of your comfort zone at the edge of
your abilities so let's say you're a
medium medium talent rock climber right
you don't want to just try and climb
over your garden wall it's not going to
get you into flow
equally you don't want to try and
suddenly climb like you know one of
those mountains in colorado that's
really high you'll just [ __ ] yourself
you want to choose a rock face that is
slightly higher and harder than the last
rock face you climbed
so if you do these three things
choose one goal make it a meaningful
goal make it one at the edge of your
abilities you massively maximize your
chances of getting into a flow state and
being able to do that deep form of
attention but there's lots of other
things that we can do i recommend really
long social media breaks i take half the
year completely off social media and i'm
so much more productive in those six
months than i am in the six months when
i'm on it um i sleep much more than i
used to
i mentioned the k safe i lot i bind
myself in i lock that [ __ ] away i you
know because i know that i'll crack if i
just leave it sitting there um but
there's one about kids that i think is
really important as well because in a
way if we're not building the baseline
of focus and attention for children
you know this is going to be an even
bigger problem 20 thirty years from now
you're sending kids to get into a flow
state or no just generally for children
and attention but generally before we
get to kids i know we're gonna spend
time on that i want to talk about that
flow state because we have a lot of
entrepreneurs on our channel people that
are in business some of the things you
were talking about they have a very much
similarity to what we talk about here
what you talk about here is rather than
doing a handful of tasks gets you know
focused on that and what we call that is
being a specialist being versus being a
jack of all trades it's the first thing
i thought of it's like okay if you want
to be good at something
focus on one thing and be great at that
one thing everyone wants to talk about
having you know
double sources of income and like
multiple uh incomes coming in it's like
no let's just get one income solidified
and then number two
you said what
um meaningful goal
so for that they say you have to work
about something that you're passionate
about you don't have to you don't have
to you know pat's passion is baseball
cards but that wasn't his or baseball i
wasn't gonna be a baseball player or
collect baseball cards for a living i
don't understand american sports no
matter how long
it's a [ __ ] excuse me
but basically you know choose something
that you know
you'll specialize in that you're
passionate about and then last but not
least your comfort zone will kill you
push yourself to the point where you're
like
i don't know if i really want to do that
but i'll go for it but so it seems to be
an analogous to to basically
the business stuff that you talked about
did you did you did you kind of pick
that up when you say i mean tyler just
pulled something up david if he can show
this
uh how to take bill gates's think week
to recover from life
every year he takes a week bill gates he
goes to a cabin no phone no laptop no
nothing and you think about guys like
jeff bezos
richard branson all the
multi-billionaires that are innovators
what do they do every morning they wake
up and they meditate they don't have
their phones they don't have their
eyeballs
or they read they sit they think well
there's speculation that a friend of
them would meet him at this thing quick
place but that's a different
conversation
but let me let me go i i i think i uh
there's a story though
but there is a story there tell me
offline but i'm no longer married
what i like about this is i fully uh
subscribe to this i
you know i sometimes would say hey i'm
going over here i'm going to be here for
a day
don't bother me if you need to get a
hold of me here's my room number here's
this well you said the story about when
you went to harvard business school
he says don't touch your phone don't
worry about it we got this thing we're
going to take care of it just how hard
was that for you to do i'm
mathematically impossible
you do not regret it do you always want
the best things i did but this is this
is why yeah you know it's so interesting
about touching your phone the average
person touches their phone 2 617 times a
day right and it used to be 150 just 10
years ago i know it's massively
expensive
2 617 it's probably higher now because
that was that research was done before
so you think about you're excited about
the reason the subtitle for the book is
and how to think deeply again is for
exactly this reason right because we
were talking before about some of the
benefits right and there are real
benefits from the speedy way in which we
live it's very important to acknowledge
that
but one of the costs is when you go
really fast you lose depth and you in
all innovation and all originality and
all creativity come from depth right so
what happens is we're constantly living
in in the shallows in these in in these
um
this kind of manic mode so if you don't
make space and we've got to be honest
with people you know the way professor
joel nick who i mentioned before one of
the leading
experts on children's attention problems
put it to me as he said we live in what
he called an attentional pathogenic
environment which means this is an
environment where it's very hard for
people to do the right thing and focus
deeply the number of people who can do
what bill gates does is very small right
the number of people who can do what
what what we're proposing currently is
small and the only thing i think in this
whole conversation i think the only
thing i've disagreed with and i
understand why you say it because part
of me thinks it is you said before i
can't see where i wrote it down but you
said something like
this is never going to change right
you're going to always be in an
environment that's going to be and of
course there's always going to be some
distractions you'll write about that
there's always going to be a human
struggle between you know you can go
back to monks a thousand years ago and
they still struggled a little bit with
well i could be distracted by this thing
or i could do this other thing
but we're living an environment now that
is hugely damaging our attention right
um and there are and i do think we've
got to understand that
because a we can protect ourselves and
our kids better when we understand it
but b because the environment can change
right think about leaded paint right
when we were kids we were exposed to
lead that damaged our attention right
damages everyone's attention you could
have said then i'm sure you wouldn't
have but you someone could people did
say that oh you know this is always
going to be a problem right how are you
ever going to deal with it but actually
we did deal with it right and for all of
the other 12 factors that we're talking
about there are very practical solutions
so let's think about the ones that
relate to kids in particular because i'm
fascinated by so we can look at the
school system but set that aside for a
minute right there's a huge change that
i think we're really well suited to see
people our age
um so tell the story in the book of a
woman called lenore scanasi who you guys
should totally have on you absolutely
love her hero
so lenore
lynel grew up in a suburb of chicago in
the 1960s
and
kind of normal suburb and from when she
was five years old she would leave home
on her own to go to school and she'd
walk on her own to the school which was
15 minutes away she'd generally bump
into the other kids that all walked
together when they got to the school
gate there was a 10 year old boy whose
job was to help the five-year-olds cross
the street right
she going to school she'd stayed there
till 3 o'clock or whatever the time was
she'd leave on her own she'd play games
with the other kids in the neighborhood
and she'd find her way home for like 6
p.m right
by the time lenoir had kids of her own
in the 90s she was living in queens in
new york
that had completely ended right she was
expected to walk her child to school and
be waiting at the school gate when he
came out by 2003 only 10 of american
children
ever played outside right without an
adult ever and i think of the 10 who did
the average amount of time they did was
like 12 minutes so basically childhood
suddenly moved even before covid to be
something that happened basically in
imprisonment right children are hidden
behind closed doors the only place they
ever get to explore anything is on
fortnight and world of warcraft so we
can hardly be surprised they become
absolutely obsessed with them right and
it's not a coincidence i think that this
complete transformation of childhood
which we were just on the cusp of like i
played outside did you guys play outside
yeah of course all the time exactly
completely we we're we're basically the
last people in the western world who as
kids got to play outside and i don't
think it's a coincidence that this huge
transformation of childhood
coincided with an enormous increase in
children's attention problems because if
you look at this
unprecedented change that's happened
there's never been a generation of human
children ever who were kept inside their
homes when we were kids or when our
parents were kids if someone kept their
child locked away all day i mean that
would have been regarded as child abuse
right
this transformation contains all sorts
of smaller changes that have [ __ ]
people's attention think about a really
simple one
exercise the evidence that exercise is
good for your brain is
overwhelming it massively improves your
attention if you're struggling to focus
go for a run right we have prevented our
children from exercising only 73 of
elementary schools in the united states
have any form of recess right if you
wanted to [ __ ] up children's ability to
focus you would be so crazy
73 have any so
that's 27 have no recess so three out of
four do have recess yeah but even those
it's very small right so and a quarter
have no recess at all right so you can
see i would ditch so but the reason why
lenore is such a hero
is because look i can tell that to you
and you're a parent and i'm sure you
think yeah that's true but also you're
like if i'm the only person who lets my
kid go out to play the kid gets scared
and i look like a crazy person so lenore
built a big part of the solution so that
obviously most of my book style and
focus is about how we solve these
problems
and lenora i think
pioneered a key part for kids
so what she does is she goes to whole
schools and whole neighborhoods she runs
something called let grow and her
parents listen and go to let grow.org
she goes to whole schools and
neighborhoods and persuades them to let
their kids go out to let them she
believes that for children to be able to
become functioning adults they have to
be able to experience increasing levels
of independence in their lives right you
have to face challenges you become
resilient exactly what you're saying you
have to have a little bit of suffering
you have to get lost literally just
saying this yesterday at least
you have to climb the tree and you know
maybe you're gonna maybe you're gonna
hurt yourself what we've done is we've
we've taken that away so what lenore
does they go and they persuade
whole communities to start to restore
childhood and one of the most moving
experiences i had for the book was i
spent a lot of time with the let grow
projects i went to one in long island
and there was a boy there a 14 year old
boy and i'll give you a sense of this
he's a big strong 14 year old boy
who until this program had begun
his parents had never let him out of his
home on his own right they wouldn't even
let him go for a jog around the block
and they said it was i asked him why and
he said it's because they're afraid of
all these kidnappings he said to give
you a sense of this this is a town in
long island where the french bakery is
across the street from the olive oil
store
and he had a level of fear that would
have been appropriate if he lived in
colombia at the height of pablo
escobar's terror right it was insane um
so this program began
him and his friends start to go outside
without their screens
they start to play with each other which
they'd never done before and after a few
months what these boys did they went
into the woods and they built a fort
and
and they went there even though their
cell phones didn't work there because
the pleasures of building something of
exploring the real world and i remember
when that boy left
lenoir said to me lenore was with me
that day
she said think about all of human
history
right young men had to go out they had
to hunt they had to seek they had to
build things
and in the space of one generation we
took all that away and those boys given
just a little bit of freedom what did
they do they went and they built a fort
right this is so important for attention
to be able to explore and build if you
just blunt a child
and it was so sad because i was thinking
about all the kids i know
who don't ever get that does does that
all ring treat you guys
i mean i lived in germany if in iran my
dad wouldn't let me play outside because
he was so worried about
you know what they were doing the
climate wasn't healthy for kids to play
outside although my dad would take us
out on friday to parque shahan shahi
it was the shah's name they changed
their name since there and we would play
outside we would he would always want to
take us outside except not without him
once we went to germany at a refugee
camp
i was out in the streets till 10 o'clock
at night my mom had no clue where i was
at and let me tell you
my uh maturity from being a boy who was
timid and couldn't be around people to
being a man happened in germany at a
refugee camp from 10 years old to 12
years old if it wasn't for those two
years at germany playing with
catherine
and katarina staff and jan and all those
guys johan from poland and you know
learning about yugoslavia a friend of
ours was from anna maria was her name
and they live in canada we found each
other on facebook it just wouldn't be
the same i totally agree with you on the
dependent side i want to get into gaming
but before i go into gaming with kids
breaking news tom brady officially
announces retirement for people in
america that's a big deal i understand i
[ __ ] live here i know about that if
you can pull up his tweet go to his
twitter account he posted a picture and
i just want to read this click on click
on tom brady go on his twitter profile
he put a picture and under it he put a
note okay
so no go to tom brady's yeah go right
there uh
okay you can do it i'll just read that
to him then that's fine okay so if you
want to zoom in a little bit uh um
tyler are you okay just zoom in a little
bit there you go okay i've always
believed the sport of football is an
all-in proposition if a 100 competitive
commitment it's a if 100 competitive
commitment isn't there you won't succeed
and successes of what i love so much
about our our game there is a physical
mental and emotional challenge every
single day that has allowed me to
maximize my highest potential and i've
tried my very best the past 22 years
there are no shortcuts to success on the
field or in life this is difficult for
me to write but here it goes i'm not
going to make that competitive
commitment anymore i have loved my nfl
career and now it's time to focus my
time and energy on other things that
require my attention
what's the [ __ ] word
focus it's official he is gone and
there's another picture of him reading
this book i don't know if you've seen
this yeah he read this book yesterday he
made this announcement
i'll get oprah to text him by the way
it's it is very ironic that he's that
his signs off with
and it is now time to focus my time and
energy on the other things that require
my attention i think not to hammer this
point home too hard but i do think
that's because
when you think about a good life when
you're reevaluating obviously tom brady
and i will never understand this [ __ ]
sport no matter how many times i watch
it no matter how many times it's
explained to me but i understand he's
good at it when tom brady is
reconsidering his whole life
um
what what does he turn to he says i want
to focus my attention right
we know i think most people watching
know that our attention is getting worse
they can feel it they can see it in
their kids and i think most people know
that's a bad thing and what i want to
say to people
is it doesn't have to be this way right
we can deal with the things that are
doing this to us but it requires a shift
in our consciousness and partly we have
to uh make individual adjustments to us
and our kids and partly we need to make
these collective solutions but also we
need to see
you know we are not [ __ ] medieval
peasants
begging at the court of king zuckerberg
for a few little crumbs of attention
from his table right we are the free
citizens of democracies and we own our
own minds and we can take them back if
we agree we own our minds and our bodies
and we should choose what to do with it
i totally agree with that those things
are being invaded at the moment and
[ __ ] with right in ways that we can
resist but we've got to know where our
power lies right some of the power lies
in what i can do as an individual what
you can do as an individual what you can
do as a parent with your kids what i can
do with my gods my nephews and my niece
but also some of our power lies in what
we can do together
to take on these forces that are doing
this to us and i think we've got to do
both because just like we took on the
lead industry yeah if we'd never taken
on the lead industry they'd still be
[ __ ] the lead industry would one day
gone you know what guys i think we've
made enough money let's stop poisoning
kids brains we never said that right can
we focus just right there let me just
ask one question
so who concerns you more who concerns
you more who wants to make us do what
they want us to do does the government
concern you more or these virtual
governments that have become very
powerful meaning the social media
companies who concerns you more
government or the big capitalist
i mean
it depends what what issue you know
there's some look government can do good
things and government can do bad things
these social media companies can do good
things or can do bad things so i think
it just it just depends on what the
issue is um
it's not about being blanketly opposed
to
any of these things that there are good
things these companies have done as well
as really harmful things think about
something as simple as
gay kids can find each other now right
in a way that was much harder when they
were you know
20 30 years ago there's all sorts of
things that have changed that are much
better right all sorts of positive
transformations
but
we're also facing these real forms of
harm so essentially we i can't remember
we haven't talked about food have we
should we talked about obesity but we
didn't talk about the way food is
actually harming attention do you want
to talk about that for a minute because
i think it might help people to think
about this you know what i would like to
talk about because i would like to talk
about gaming so you should pull up that
link i sent you yeah uh so so gaming so
yeah
esports has blown up okay
last year's international 2021
tournament the the total purse payout
to kids and people playing video games
was 40 million dollars okay that's 20
million dollars all the kids now here's
the thing what do you think first place
scott what do you think first place got
out of the 40 million dollars i'm
curious because he's going to show it to
you right now in a minute what do you
think first place got out of the 40
million dollars 10 million bucks okay go
click on first place click on it
guys so first place make it a little
bigger first place 18 million bucks okay
so 48 of it yeah so now here's what's
going on with uh at the same time so
there's more people watching the last uh
uh there's a number that they showed
that live stream that more people watch
the championship of esports than the
super bowl okay so so this is the mind
just exploded yeah i don't know if
there's brains all over the world this
is by the way this is turning oh by the
way the sponsorships they're getting
multi-million dollar a year sponsorship
is being given to 16 year olds 17 year
olds 14 year olds 22 year olds they're
making that kind of money right now
these gamers are right so
this is the challenge the people that
are struggling with this this the most
are parents okay
because parents are sitting there saying
dude i grew up in a phase where you went
and played games you want to play
football you want to play basketball you
want to play soccer football you know
whatever the game may be
that you're doing now my kid's coming
home all he's talking about is roblox
he's talking about league of legends
he's talking about all of these
tournaments that are taking place and
what do i do don't play video games
because that's what we're supposed to do
i grew up in sega genesis i grew up on
super mario brothers i grew up in all
these things you know
all these crazy things that we grew up
with
yeah yeah the street fighter mortal
kombat these were the games arcade right
we shouldn't do that versus now
they're
they're now
you know looking at this as a
industry this could be their jobs kids
could make video games kids could be
gamers making a hundred thousand quarter
million half a million a million dollars
and that's their passion that's what
they love
what do you say
to
uh uh parents who worry on how to handle
video games with their kids especially
now that it's no longer just a game that
you're playing it's becoming an industry
that's funny when you said that about
the games when we were kids because i
about maybe six months ago i was playing
fortnight with one of my godsons joe
who was 10 at the time
and i said to him hey joe do you want to
see what video games were like when i
was a kid and he's like yeah
and we played you remember frogger do
you remember this
so we played frogger for like three
minutes and he turned to me and he put
his hand on mine and absolutely
sincerely he said johan
i'm so sorry things were so [ __ ] when
you were a kid
[Music]
ted he looked cool he looked at me like
the way if i take it into like a wooden
shack where you lived in [ __ ]
so i think we're video games like a
black and white tv versus a new hd uh
everything that you're gonna
say it's totally different so i think
with video games um there's a few i have
a few thoughts um so one is there's
loads of good things about video games
right it gives firstly it gives a lot of
people a lot of pleasure that's a good
thing in itself uh secondly it improves
hand-eye coordination there's all sorts
of really great things my view is video
games are a good thing in a balanced
diet really they are so there's no
problem i have no problem go to kfc once
a week it's fine just don't go to kfc
three times a day right in the same way
so the chinese government and i want to
stress i do not support this because the
chinese government is a communist
tyranny and it's awful but the chinese
government has introduced a rule uh
saying that kids are allowed to play
video games for three hours a week right
and it's a strict rule it's enforced um
that seems to me although i wouldn't
want to have a communist tyranny
imposing it i'd want parents to choose
it that seems to me like a perfectly
sensible three hours a day that's fine
three hours a week rather that's fine
obviously most american kids are doing
way more than that the thing i'm worried
about much more
is the context in which they're playing
the video games because like we were
saying if a child never gets to go
outside right if the kids are sort of
imprisoned and all they've got is the
video game well i'm not surprised they
become obsessed with it right if the
children need to explore their
environment right our children don't get
to explore their environment they don't
get to go off on their own and play in
the park and play in the woods and just
do all the normal things that we did
right they they don't get to do that
so what do they do they become obsessed
with the one form of exploration they're
allowed to do right now being obsessed
with it isn't good a balanced diet is
fine you know going to kfc every now and
then play video games how do you deal
with because you see your kids play
video games yeah only on the weekends
okay so that's that was my question
how do you how do you manage
expectations with them to say all right
guys if you get your stuff done during
the week the weekends you can choose to
do it like choose what you want with
your free time if they choose video
games great if they want to go play
outside how do you deal with your kids
with that oh i mean you know you've
known what we do with the structure with
the kids every day if you want to play
video games or if you want anything the
currency in our house is books right so
after you read 20 pages after you move
your body exercise and then
you can play so
you have to watch a documentary so we've
gone through uh the men who built
america we've gone through a last dance
documentary we've gone through history
of capitalism we're going right now
through
man in the arena with uh what do you
call it
tom brady so 20 minutes doc
exercise moving your body then you get
to play video games but it is their
ultimate reward to say yeah i that's
that's if that's what they wanted to do
but no the other day they said we wanted
to go to such and such park which i went
there and we were at the park for an
hour they didn't want to play video
games we went to the park so park and
they played with these kids with the
nerf guns and they had a blast what they
did at the park but you know i think
about myself were you a gamer did you
play games or no were you very i was
more the kid that was playing football
in the yeah you already had the sidewalk
yeah so i played fester's quest which if
you
do you remember
if you remember fester's quest
you're either my age or like type in
fester's quest this was my game this is
like a business
final fantasy rpg games i was addicted
so you were a gamer i i would say i was
a gamer for two years and then i went to
the army we played the fifa soccer and
then one day i had zero interest when i
got out of the army like zero i'm like i
have no time for this i'm done and i
dropped it and i moved on i want to give
you some statistics and i want to get
your thoughts on this so
uh psychiatric times wrote this article
is video game addiction a disorder
in ohio a 17 year old boy shot both of
his parents killed killing his mother
because what a great story you put here
tyler thank you for the soft story he's
feeling good because he took away his
halo because they took away his halo 3
video game his defense was that he was
pushed to the brink uh by his addiction
to video games often playing for 18
hours straight and south korea a couple
was arrested for being so obsessed with
video games that their infant daughter
died of malnutrition okay now this is
these guys have issues here 18 hours a
day in response to statistics like this
the world health organization in 2018
officially included internet gaming
disorder icd in the international
classification of diseases noting that
this is disorder resulted in marked
distress or significant impairment in
personal family social educational
occupational functioning who further
noted that associate health concerns
including insufficient physical activity
poor diet problems and eyesight
with eyesight and hearing
sleep deprivation aggressive behavior
and depression as well as poor cycle a
psychological functioning in 2020
consumers in the u.s spent
57 billion on video games beating 2019
by 27
projections that by 2023 next year that
57 billion is going to be 217
billion dollars how much of this is on
the kid how much of this is on the
society how much of this is on their
parents
i think there's a bigger debate about
addiction we can come to in a second but
if you think about these video games
this is going to be too negative an
analogy but let me say it and then i'll
explain why it's a bit too negative if
you think about them as a virus right
that come along that would be compelling
in any situation
they've arrived at a moment when kids
immune systems are already down right so
they're more likely to be infected by
the virus and for it to take them over
so i'll give you two examples
children now sleep 85 minutes less than
they did a century ago now you all know
we all know if we've had a night where
we haven't slept you're much more likely
to just spend next day mindlessly scroll
through tiktok than you are to read a
book right so partly our kids are
severely sleep deprived and that is
making them more vulnerable to this
stuff also the diet our children eat um
the food we feed our kids makes them
much more vulnerable to this stuff as
well and i stress again some of it some
of the video gaming is good but you
think about how we eat there's three big
ways in which the way we our kids eat
and the way we in fact is damaging our
ability to focus and make us more
vulnerable to the kind of things you're
describing the first is so imagine you
have the standard american british
breakfast the kind of thing i grew up
having i'm sure you guys did kind of
sugar or in germany sugary cereal or
white bread with butter or whatever
right what that does is that releases a
huge amount of energy really quickly
into your brain right and it feels great
you're like i've [ __ ] woken up you
know you've got a rush of glucose but
what happens is you'll get to your desk
or your kid will get to their school
desk an hour or two later and you get a
huge energy crash because you know the
way dale pinnock one of the leading
nutritionists in britain put it to me
is it's like you're putting rocket fuel
into a mini with those little british
cars that's right it'll go really fast
for five minutes then it will just stop
right so the way we eat causes energy
spikes and energy crashes which leaves
you with brain fog when your energy
crashes you get brain fog you just can't
think clearly until you have another
sugary carby snack right so
one of the things that we're doing is we
if you
by contrast if you eat a food if you eat
food that releases energy steadily
throughout the day which is what you
know almost all our ancestors ate you're
able to pay attention more evenly and
you're less likely to just get into
these slumps where just anything that
wants to [ __ ] with your attention will
seem appealing second way
our diet is damaging our ability to
focus
is the um
your brain in order to develop properly
needs certain nutrients and the diet we
currently is lacking a lot of those
nutrients like omega-3s and supplements
don't cut it because your body doesn't
absorb supplements in the same way third
way is to me the most shocking and i
think to you as a dad most
most relevant although they all are
which is there was a it's not just that
our diets lack things we need
they contain chemicals that act on us
like drugs so there's a study in britain
in a city called southampton in 2007
they got nearly 300 kids and they split
them into two groups the first group was
just given water and the second group
was given water lace with a load of the
food dyes that occur in the kind of food
you get in the supermarket in m ms that
kind of thing
and then they monitored them the kids
that drank the food dies were
significantly more likely to become
manic to run around which would have
made them more vulnerable to the kind of
things you're talking about so you can
see how and these are just two of the
many factors that i talk about in the
book that are affecting our kids
attention so you can see how that's like
lowering your immune system so that when
something that wants to [ __ ] with your
attention comes along it's easier for it
to infect the child which is not to say
there aren't healthy uses of video games
there totally are i'm not opposed to
video games just like i'm not opposed to
technology or the internet more
generally but we've got to look at these
things but there's a bigger debate about
addiction that i can talk about where i
think this video game addiction stuff
um how would i put it
i think it can be interpreted this is
not what you're doing but i think it can
be interpreted simplistically and this
is because i went on a long journey
about learning about addiction for a
previous book i wrote called chasing the
screen where
there's a lot of addiction in my family
one of my
earliest memories um it was it was
mostly prescription drugs um
so one of my earliest memories is trying
to wake up one of my relatives and not
being able to and um
fun enough similar places iran and
germany were two to the countries my
family lived in as well so similar to
you um
and
when i started doing research on
dictionary almost exactly 10 years ago
if you had asked me about let's say
heroin addiction because that was also
close to me
if you'd ask me what causes heroin
addiction
i would have looked at you like you're
an idiot and i would have said well
patrick the clue's in the name
obviously heroin causes heroin addiction
we've been told this story for a hundred
years that's become totally part of our
common sense i thought it was
i mean i thought i'd seen it unfold in
front of me right
so we think if we kidnapped the next 20
people to walk past your offices here in
florida
and we injected them every day with
heroin three times a day for a month say
like a villain in a sore movie
at the end of that month they'd all be
heroin addicts for a simple reason
there's chemical hooks in heroin that
their bodies would start to get used to
and then their bodies would start to
desperately physically crave them and so
at the end of it they would have this
tremendous physical hunger for the
chemical hooks right that's why we call
it being hooked right you want the
chemical hook
it turns out that story's not wrong
chemical hooks are real but it's a
really small part of what's happening
with addiction
and when you look at the bigger picture
um and i only really began to understand
this when i went to vancouver and
interviewed a man named professor bruce
alexander who did an experiment that has
transformed how we think about addiction
so he explained to me the story we got
in our heads addiction is caused
primarily or tightly by the chemical
hooks comes from a series of experiments
that were done earlier in the 20th
century they're really simple
experiments your viewers can try them at
home if they're feeling a little bit
sadistic
you take a rat you put it in a cage and
you give it two water bottles one is
just water and the other is water laced
with either heroin or cocaine
if you do that the rat will almost
always prefer the drug water and almost
always kill itself within a couple of
weeks it'll overdose so there you go
that's our story the rat tries the drug
wants more and more of it dies
but in the 70s professor alexander came
along and said well hang on a minute
you're putting the rat alone
in an empty cage
it's got nothing that makes life
meaningful for rats all it's got is the
drugs what would happen if we did this
differently
so he built a cage that he called rat
park which is basically heaven for rats
right they got loads of friends they got
loads of cheese they got loads of
coloured balls they could have loads of
sex anything a rat likes in life is
there in wrap park and they've got the
drug water the normal water and the drug
water and of course they try both they
don't know what's in them this is the
fascinating thing
in rat park they don't like the drug
water very much
none of them use it compulsively
none of them overdose so you go from
almost 100 compulsive use and overdose
when they don't have the things that
make life worth living to no compulsive
use and overdose when they have what you
were talking about before meaning
purpose the things that make life worth
living for them and what i learned from
this there's loads of human examples we
can talk about but what i learned from
this is that the opposite of addiction
is not sobriety valuable though that is
to many people the opposite of addiction
is connection and the reason i say this
in response to this video game addiction
uh stuff you read out patrick
is
i think it's too simplistic to say oh
the video game this boy that you
described i don't know how old he was 17
yeah the 17 year old boy it's way too
simplistic to say the video game did
that to him right the video game did
that to him in a context where also i'm
sure absolutely the story but i'm sure
all sorts of things were [ __ ] him up
and every addictive behavior
whether it's video games cocaine porn
whatever it might be
is an attempt to not be present in your
life because your life is too painful a
place to be right you want to not be
present so you obsessively use the porn
you obsessively play video games
whatever it might be that helps us to
understand by the way why what we do
here in the us
is such a [ __ ] disaster with the war
on drugs because what we do is we get
addicted people and we say oh we need to
inflict more pain on them in order to
give them an incentive to stop but when
you know that pain is the [ __ ] fuel
pain is the driver you can see sometimes
we say it doesn't work truth is much
worse it makes the addiction worse right
does that all what do you make of that
about your thoughts the first thing that
popped in my mind you said is is
all right they're in a cage
so the thing that comes to my mind is
we've seen the stats on what's happened
since kovit everybody's been locked in
their cage right other than maybe here
in florida and other certain other
states
so
if you have the choice of just sipping
on water or sipping on water with heroin
if you're the rat and you're in your
cage you're going to take the heroin
using a human example if you're sitting
at home alone doing nothing
you know you have to work apparently
maybe you're not maybe you're collecting
unemployment you're getting stimulus
checks maybe you've got to hop on a zoom
do work but you're locked in your
proverbial cage okay there's some liquor
in the cabinet there's some pot over
there on the desk maybe there's some
harder uh
you know pills opiates they're sitting
there you're in your cage
so i'm sensing this cajun alley is what
analogy is what leads to people saying
well based on the two options i have of
sipping on water or doing some drugs i'm
in this cage anyway let's party is that
part of what this rat cage analogy is
yeah i've got a friend um so as you know
we
interestingly i want to read this
comment before you upload it which
validates your point uh crypto trends uh
101 i used to be addicted to meth
i know sad but it's true the environment
and things worth living for are what
made me better
yeah i think this really fits with what
you're saying adam which is that so a
lot of people watching will know
in the last year we had the highest
overdose deaths ever and that's
staggering because just before the
pandemic
people thought well it can't go higher
than it is now
um and
my friend the writer andrew sullivan
said to me it's like we did an
experiment to see if you were right
right i've been saying for 10 years the
opposite of addiction is connection if
you increase disconnection you'll
increase addiction
and here we are right we increase
disconnection in what may be justified
cause but it has caused a horrific
increase in not just addiction and this
fits with a wider way of thinking right
which is that everyone listening and
everyone watching knows that you have
natural physical needs right obviously
you need food you need water you need
shelter you need clean air if i took
those things away from you you'd be in
real trouble real fast but there's
equally strong evidence that all human
beings have natural psychological needs
you need to feel you belong human
connection you need to feel your life
has meaning and purpose you need to feel
that people see you and value you you
need to feel you've got a future that
makes sense and
if you if you deprive people of their
psychological needs
that'll manifest in all sorts of
problems you'll have increased suicide
which we have you'll have increased um
homicide which we have right you'll have
increased
addiction which we have an overdose
deaths and you can see this this is why
some of the best people who've studied
this professors and case and angus
dayton called the opioid crisis deaths
of despair when a factory shuts down in
a town the over the next five years the
death rate among people who work there
more than doubles right now that's not
difficult to understand anyone who hears
that knows immediately why right
so it's not of course the drug plays a
role just like the video game may in
this case i don't think about this
particular case but the video game may
play a role but but the drug and the
video game
enter in a context and most people who
use even quite hard drugs and this
really surprised me because it wasn't
the experience of my family but if you
look at the evidence from people like
professor carl hart at columbia
university and others most people who
use even quite hard drugs like even meth
and heroin do not become addicted and
are not harmed by it now of course
there's a minority you are harmed who
need our love and support but why can
some people do it and not others there's
some biological contributions some
people have a little bit more of a
genetic
vulnerability but most of it is about
these bigger psychological and social
factors if your life's going well
you know and you're happy and you want
to be present in your life you can
probably snort a line of coke you'll be
okay
if you're if the factory is shut down
and you're stuck in a place like
monadnock new hampshire where i went
where people are in deep despair through
no fault of their own you know well it's
going to be a lot more dangerous for you
because you're going to want to not be
present in your life this is why by the
way there is a solution to this and one
of the things that makes me so [ __ ]
crazy so as you guys know i've been
spending a lot of the pandemic in vegas
in fact a lot of the last 10 years in
vegas because i'm writing a book about
vegas that i'm not meant to talk about
very much my publishers or taze me
outside in a minute but the
i spend a lot of time with people with
addiction problems in vegas
and um
and someone i really love died um
last summer
and one of the things that makes me so
crazy is in the research from my book
about this
i went to places where my friend tommy
and so many other people would have
lived and not died
so
portugal for example in the year 2000
portugal had one of the worst drug
problems in the whole world
one percent of the population was
addicted to heroin which is mind-blowing
right you walk down the street one in
every hundred people
okay staggering they were top of the
european league tables for 27 european
countries at the time
top of all the league tables for death
right and overdose and addiction
and every year they tried our way more
the american way more they arrested more
people they imprisoned more people they
shamed more people and every year the
classic war on drugs that has failed
here in america exactly what's worked so
[ __ ] well hasn't it exactly and then
one day the prime minister and the
leader of the opposition
um got together and they were like look
we can't carry on like this what are we
going to do so they decided to do
something really radical something no
one had done
in more than 70 years since the global
war on drugs began they were like
should we ask some scientists what we
should do so they set up a panel of
scientists and doctors led by an amazing
man i got to know in portugal named dr
joao gulao and they said to them you
guys go away
figure out what would solve this problem
and we've agreed in advance with all the
political parties that will do whatever
you recommend so just took it out of
politics so the panel goes away they
look at all the evidence including rat
park the experiment we were just talking
about and the panel comes back and says
you're gonna think we're crazy but
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
decriminalize all drugs from cannabis to
crack everything but and this is the
crucial next step we're going to take
all the money we used to spend on
[ __ ] people up more shaming them
imprisoning them arresting them putting
them on trial and we're going to spend
all that money instead on helping them
turn their lives around and
interestingly wasn't mostly what we
think of as drug treatment in the u.s
they did a little bit of residential
rehab which has value most of it was
about getting people back to work say
you used to be a mechanic you got an
addiction problem they go to a garage
they say if you employ this guy for a
year
we'll pay half his wages the job the
goal was to say to every single person
with an addiction problem in portugal
we love you
we value you
we're on your side we want you back and
by the time i went to portugal it was 13
years since this had begun and the
results were in best research was done
by the british journal of criminology
who don't have a dog in this fight they
found that they portugal had gone from
having the worst overdose death in the
european union to being almost the
bottom of the league table um addiction
was down by more than 50 percent um
overdose deaths were down by more than
80 percent there was just an enormous
transformation and one of the ways you
know it works so well
is that almost nobody in portugal wants
to go back i went and interviewed a guy
called schweil figuera who was the top
drug cop in portugal at the time of the
decriminalization and he said what loads
of people totally understandably say
when you say let's decriminalize your
drugs he said this is insane we'll have
a huge increase in children using drugs
this is a nightmare we can't do it he
said to me
everything i said would happen didn't
happen
and everything the other side said would
happen did and he said he felt really
ashamed when he looked back that he
realized he spent so many years making
people's lives worse when he could have
been helping them make their lives
better
and this is something i saw all over the
world from uruguay to switzerland to
portugal when countries move beyond the
war on drugs at first is super
controversial people think you're
[ __ ] insane
and then people see the results right
switzerland legalized heroin since then
there have been more than 15 years ago
now since then there have been zero
heroin overdose deaths on legal heroin
none not one person right more people
have died of heroin overdoses in this
country since we started talking then on
legal heroin in all the years they've
had it now in switzerland
all these countries because they help
people right policies based on shame
stigma and punishment make addiction
worse policies based on love compassion
and regulating the market bringing the
market away from criminals and under
control
massively reduce the problems they're
not a magic bullet they still have some
problems but but they work so much
better have you done any research on
what they've done in oregon
yeah yes this happened
decriminalizing legalized all drugs
yeah yeah so the different street
decriminalisation here in the united
states yeah so what is your research
shown on that so uh i'll just explain
the difference between decriminalization
legalization so decriminalization is
where you stop punishing users and
people with addiction problems but they
still have to go to armed criminals to
get their drugs
legalization is where you open up some
legal route for people to get their
drugs and that should be different for
every drug obviously no one wants there
to be a heroin island cvs that's not the
answer right
so
oregon can decriminalize unfortunately
they can't legalize because um federal
federal law i mean they have
decriminalized they're decriminalized
so oregon wasn't able to do what
portugal did
so tightly which is transfer the money
they used to spend but we know that the
outcomes in oregon are pretty promising
at the moment it's a very recent change
compared to portugal where it's been in
place for
17 years now but we but we know
everywhere else in the world that's done
it has had
radical improvements
and the truth is you want you want to
say anything in defense of the war on
drugs you can say one thing we gave it a
fair shot we did it for a hundred years
we spent a trillion dollars
we imprisoned millions of our own
citizens we destroyed whole neighboring
countries or close by countries like
colombia and at the end of all that
we can't even keep drugs out of our
prisons where we pay guards to walk
around the world perimeter the whole
time we aren't that strategy has been
tested to destruction there is no
country in the world that anyone can
point to where it has worked there are
loads of countries where policies based
on love and compassion and order and
regulation
work so at some point we've got to stop
copying the countries that have
disastrously failed and start copying
the places that have succeeded um yeah
very interesting how about porn
addiction let's talk about porn
addiction because some people in the
comments section i was very ecstatic
about talking about porn addiction i
wonder why but so were they orgasmic
about talking yeah well they were on a
different website and they just jumped
on this and that different website we'll
talk about here in a minute
psychology today porn addiction more
than 90 percent of young men report
watching porn videos with some
regularity particularly in the united
states apparently u.s kids like porn
more than other states many of these
videos depict acts that might never
engage in themselves in other words
erotic fantasies on pornhub the world's
largest
porn website alone well over 90 billion
videos are viewed daily by more than 64
million visitors apparently 90 billion
with only 7 billion people living here
apparently aliens are watching this i
don't know what's going on with that
number
64 million visitors daily 26 of them are
women females although viewing erotica
is nearly uh ubiquitous among males some
men and women regard watching internet
porn as pathological and believe that at
some time spent doing so may be a sign
of porn addiction although such a
diagnosis is rejected by many
psychologists and our treatment
approaches based on addiction models so
it continues to talk about all these
other things on why
it's good and why it's bad what are your
thoughts on porn addiction have you done
any kind of research on that or i did
research this it's an amazing young guy
now what is research does research mean
you sit there for weeks watching
profile foreign uh porn addiction expert
researcher you guys should have on this
fantastic guy called alexander rhodes
who was part of my research we did not
masturbate together i want to stress uh
he's in pittsburgh he he runs a site
called nofap which is uh
no fap yeah that he he became uh
obsessed with with porn so there's a few
things we're thinking about in relation
to porn it's a bit like video games i'm
not anti-porn right
pawn will meet a certain basic hitch
we'll watch it sometimes i don't take an
anti-pawn position
um there's a lot of itches going on
itching powder it fixes it
yeah exactly people are confused listen
that's his english he uses folks he's
not saying anymore
as you can tell from my word downton
abbey yeah the um but you know it's
interesting i went to the first ever
internet rehab center in the world it's
a place called restart washington yeah
it's just outside spokane
and so interesting so they get all all
sorts of people in this internet rehab
center but they disproportionately get
young men who become obsessed either
with online role-playing games or with
porn
and it was so fascinating talking to
these
particularly
spoke to the young men a lot but also dr
hilary cash
set up and runs a click he's a really
wise person
i remember her saying to me afterwards
she said you know you've got to and this
relates to your video game thing as well
she said you've got to ask yourself
what are these young men getting out of
these games right or we can think about
this in relation to porn so they're
getting something they used to get from
the culture but they no longer get so
they're getting with the video games
a sense they're physically roaming
around we've talked about that young
people don't get to do that
they get a sense they're good at
something we have a culture that does
not make young men think they're good at
anything a particular school system um
but what they get is almost like a kind
of parody of those things and i started
to think about it in relation to porn as
well
because
in a way i think the relationship
between so the relationship between
social media and social life is a bit
like the relationship between porn and
sex
i'm not anti-porn at all
but if your whole sex life consisted of
just one kid over porn
you go around pretty pissed off and
grouchy all the time because we didn't
evolve to masturbate over screens we
evolved to actually have sex right no
one after an hour looking at porn feels
satisfied the way they do after having
sex at least if it weren't right
um
so i think there's a degree to which um
what's the context in which this
addiction is occurring right
the context is a context in which
young men are often made to feel
incompetent they're often made to feel
they're not good at anything um they're
often made to feel frustrated like if
you look at what's happened with the the
in the wider economy um
a lot of particularly working-class
people
cannot earn enough to feel they can
provide for a woman for a family right
there's no city in the united states
where a minimum minimum wage worker can
rent a one-bedroom apartment not one
there's none
so i think if you create a sense of
humiliation among young men that makes
them less appealing to women it makes
women less interested in them
um
that can you can see how that's a kind
of environment where porn addiction
begins to develop and i want to
distinguish very clearly between someone
who looks at porn every now and then and
you know just to chill out or release
some stress and people who become
addicted that's a very different thing
just like we all know if we go into the
nearest bar to here
most people there are going to be
drinking alcohol to have a good time and
there's going to be a small minority who
have an alcohol addiction problem who
deserve love and compassion so i think i
would always wonder with every addiction
you always want to look at what's the
context
in which this addiction is occurring
what's the problem the person is trying
to solve what's the pain that they're in
that they're trying to not be present
with so in a way if you think about the
addictive behavior is almost like the
surface phenomena you want to deal with
what's the deeper question here oh
you're lonely 41 of americans agree with
the statement no one knows me well right
this is the loneliest society in human
history um one study uh has asked people
for a good few years how many close
friends do you have you could turn to in
a crisis and when they started doing it
years ago the most common answer was
five today the most common answer is
none right now a lonely society is going
to be a society where people are going
to find opioids more appealing they're
going to find just jerking off over
pornhub more appealing they're going to
find
you know obsessively doing it if you're
cut off from the normal
necessities of life if your
psychological needs aren't met you're
going to be more vulnerable to addiction
whether it's porn cannabis whatever
there's two comments i want to give
credit to one of them i don't understand
the other one i think
one of them says uh uh
uh he says uh david jones is his name
porn made my 10 year old mind think if i
did not look and perform like john
holmes i was a failure
what a travesty right
and larry medina says my socks are
pretty satisfying
so uh mysterious comment i i think
there's a separate question about kids
seeing porn and i definitely think we
don't want to be in a situation where i
mean i remember speaking about going to
the woods i remember when we were kids
i remember the first time i ever saw
paul when i was 11 years old jim people
used to leave matt paul magazines in the
woods i don't know what the [ __ ] that
was about uh and i remember i didn't
like put out a little magazine every
like a handful of meters yeah i was that
lure you're into
was there a van at the end of the earth
but i remember getting the van i
remember seeing what i saw was like very
very soft core
um and i remember not seeing it again
until i was i guess i found my brother's
porn when i was like 14 or something
i've got an older brother
but
the difference between that you do not
want your son's eight you don't want him
in a couple of years to be discovering
his first understanding of sex to be
[ __ ] gang bangs on porn up right so i
do think there's a lot to be done with
uh regulation when it comes to children
and there are some countries that have
done it so you have to opt in so you can
see porn on your broadband option uh
which i think would embarrass a lot of
people but who cares so that you you
know there are all sorts of ways you can
block these things for kids
we definitely don't want kids to be
learning about sex from porn because
porn is not uh
you know mo the vast majority of paul is
not a healthy or realistic you tell the
story about pamela anderson and then the
story that she had with her son yeah she
sat her sons down yeah she says listen
you know she says uh she's saying this
in an interview she said uh
uh uh
you know i uh
would go out and say i'm meeting
somebody and we end up having sex he
says many times i'm like what are you
doing
what do you do that does not feel good
you know hitting me here doesn't feel
good pulling my hair i don't like it
then i would ask the person whom i'm
having sex with i'd say hey how much
porn do you watch are you thinking that
you watch this in a video like a fetish
like it feels good for women so
she was teaching her sons what you see
in porn doesn't feel good that's acting
and she was kind of trying because she's
saying like porn is traumatized men to
think they have to
perform at that level and that's coming
from pamela anderson who i think's
probably been with more than one men in
her life i don't know the exact number
or treat women yeah disrespectfully
totally doesn't like that that was the
angle kind of take it there's a really
good canadian researcher on this called
lily boiver who you guys should have on
as well she's fascinating and she talks
about this where you know the number of
men who just wanted to choke her and
slap her just quite extreme
which is not to say there aren't some
people who are consensually into those
things and that's fine but the sort of
expectation of those things which is and
she's done i can't remember the figures
because it's a few years since i
interviewed her but she's done research
that exposure to porn does increase you
know people having unrealistic
expectations of sort of fetishistic
behaviors that women will just be up for
that and you definitely don't want you
know you don't want your sons or or
indeed your daughters to be in this
situation where these are the sort of
that that's not that doesn't feel like a
liberated and healthy form of sex which
is what we want for young adults as they
start to develop you know i mean when
they get to the right age obviously
we want people to have healthy
attitudes towards sex that are not based
around shame we don't in a funny way
those feel to me more like the old
attitudes this is where a lot of shame
in wanting to be aggressive and violent
and it feels to me like quite a
conflicted attitude towards sexuality
not for everyone i don't want to king
shame anyone whatever people are into
conspiracy
course 100 people who are into
consensual behavior anything you want to
do consensually with another adult um
knock yourself out literally if you want
but the
the um
but but i do think it's worth us
thinking about the ways in which massive
exposure to pornography for very young
people
i do think can have a distorting effect
on their sexuality that's unhealthy not
in every case but i i that's the only
bit i'm worried about consensual adults
nothing they do worries me well johanna
i gotta tell you i i uh
had no idea you were this funny okay i'm
i'm watching your two ted talks i'm like
i had no idea you you were so witty with
a sense of humor and the personality i'm
so glad we were able to pull this out
folks if you're watching this
tyler let's put the link below both in
the chat box as well as a comment
section
uh if you enjoyed today's interview
subscribe to the channel as well as go
purchase this book stolen focus why you
can't pay attention and how to think
deeply again to find out about those 12
triggers that he was talking about on
how to become more focused uh next time
you're here we'd love to have you on i'd
love to do that i'm meant to say or my
publishers will tease me again that
people can also get the audio book the
ebook or the physical book if they go to
stolenfocusbook.com
and they can also listen for free to
interviews with loads of the experts
so you want them to go to what's the
name of amazon go anywhere okay i meant
to say you can buy any good football on
fire yeah yeah exactly focus.com yeah i
got in trouble at the end of a podcast a
little while ago where at the end of the
podcast the guy said to me this guy's
about 50. he said so what's your twitter
and i said it and he said what's your
facebook and i said it he said what's
your instagram and i said it and then he
said what's your snapchat and i said i
am a 42 year old man right the only 42
year old men on snapchat are definitely
pedophiles right why would they be there
and he he didn't laugh all in the night
because he didn't laugh i sort of leaned
into the joke and i said you know that
show to catch a predator yeah i said the
next season of to catch a predator
should literally just be they go up to
adult men in the street and say what is
your snapchat handle and if they have
one just immediately put them on the
cards right yeah the guy didn't laugh
all i later looked him up and he has
quite a big snapchat
i'm glad i got through this interview
without accusing either of you being
pedophiles i'm very glad we've got but i
really enjoyed this thank you for
engaging so we really really enjoyed it
thank you so much absolutely
next time we promise not to show you any
images of mcdonald's
pineapple burgers nothing i want
mcdonald's brought in every 10 minutes
yeah the next interview thursday mike
ritlin i believe friday is jordan
peterson once it's confirmed you'll see
it going up having said that have a
great day guys take care bye bye bye bye
you